大家好，我们是三时不而已。
Hello everybody!。
现在是我在深圳概谱的第八个月了。
居然已经第八个月了。
这么快？
很多人都会问我，你概谱这么久压力大不大呀？
大吗？请问。
其实还好。
我觉得早早就准备好了足够支撑我不工作很久的一笔存款。
这么厉害？
手里有粮，心里不慌。
那我可没有你这么...。
因为我当时概谱的时候我是蛮慌的。
除了前一两个月就是觉得自己在调理身体之外，
后面就开始觉得好像这样下去不行，
因为我还有外债了。
对了。
我算了一下，我不是上个月刚刚是工作满意，
就在这家公司工作满一年吗？
我发了工作也已经进入第九年了，
已经是一个老油条了。
虽然这些年不断的跳槽，
工资是有小小的提升，
但是我感觉我那个存款，
好像永远都在那个差不多的水平里面止步不前，
就是发了工资之后好像上去一点，
然后没过多久又立马回到之前的状态。
我反观自己的人生，
我也觉得我不是那种贪图享乐的性格，
偶尔我也会对别人要是有一些你知道非常月光型的那种消费观念，
我是会提出质疑的，
但是看自己的存款的，
永远都在那个地方左右摇摆，
然后我就开始算自己的消费账，
我每过一两年就开始算一次自己最近花钱怎么样，
然后发现自己就是扣扣搜搜的花了很多大钱，
比如说最近今年，
诶，去年吗？去年买了手机一万多，
今年买相机三四千，
然后动不动买个一两千的耳机，
最近又有什么自行车什么的，
反正就是也是没有少花钱，
以及还有那笔最大的消费，
就是本人现在这个录音的这个环境，
四环老破晓。
有房一族啦。
有债一族啦。
诶，你这个房子有房贷吗？
当然有啊，
每个月还是在那个持续的环带啊。
诶，我虽然回了花奥特以后，
没有了最大头就是住房的支出，
诶，但是我的工资呢，
也少了很多，比北漂时期，
我现在收入，
大家也知道，
我也概谱了，
几个月了，
三个月了，
四个月了，
我的收入主要靠做全职女儿，
靠做孝女，
对,
但是呢，
与此同时，
我的追星是一场都没落下，
OMG,
然后就是在准备这一期的时候，
我闷心自问，
我的那个追星消费，
我真的是迎头痛击了不少，
待会我会算算他的那个追星账啦，
我要给他进行一些指责，
OMG,
哇，我被这个，
这个这个现实重打了一下诶，
光今年啊，
我想想飞了几个城市了，
加上我自己的旅游的话，
一个时候，
应该是数不完了，
应该有六七个地，
真的，每个月的总结都在旅游，
哦，是呢，
诶,
这个账单没法算，
嗯，没法算了，
我们为什么要回顾自己的，
这个钱包的现状呢，
因为我们最近，
也是年纪增长之后，
就意识到诶，
自己的这辈子是不是大概就是这样了，
因为小时候都会幻想，
我干嘛说这么悲观啊，
哦，你们还很乐观吗？
诶，你们小时候会跟我一样，
就是做那种职业生涯的梦想嘛，
不是职业生涯，
就是你长大之后要成为什么的那种梦？
嗯,
要成为科学家啊，
对吧,
我小时候也是，
最早的时候，
就因为有爸妈的那个，
洗脑式教育，
就会觉得说，
哦，长大我也要成为一个科学家，
为国效力，
你要得那个诺贝尔数学奖啊，
或者是什么国家科技，
进步发展奖之类的，
你们不知道去那个新概念作文得奖吗？
那是有了自我意识之后才有了，
对，就是，
然后就有些人开始有自我意识之后，
比如说有些人想当宇航员，
有些人想成为郭敬明，
然后有些人想要成为那个，
明星,
我想成为奥斯卡引后了，
对啊，你不是想走上那个大舞台吗？
哦,
然后后来上了大学之后呢，
就是稍微开始接触一点现实，
就懂了一点人情事事之后，
就觉得说哦好，
我成不了明星，
我成不了那个李宾宾，
但是我是不是至少可以成为那种，
就是不需要父母接际，
我就可以买房买车，
然后实现接级跨越，
我要走上我的人生巅峰，
我要做一个职场精英。
那经济上行年代，
我们每个人都是杜拉拉，
不断地升职，
然后不断地加薪，
对啊，我记得以前我爸妈跟我说，
哎呀给你攒钱买房，
我就说不用，
我不需要你给我钱买房，
我自己能够转到我的钱，
我会拥有我自己成功的事业，
有幸福的人生。
但是工作了几年之后，
那个现实，
认清现实的程度越来越高，
我觉得到最近我就开始意识到，
我们都是那种，
就是普通的不能再普通，
频繁的不能再频繁的那种路人。
我们是NPC呀，
就是我们是那个演职员表，
很后面的那种就是路人甲，
路人椅子那种，
以前幻想的那种职业生涯里面，
非常辉煌的那个路径，
我觉得很有可能跟我们是毫无关系的。
没错,
就我想说，哎，
未来我还能赚得更多吗？
我的这辈子，
应该大概就是这样吧，
听上去好消极的一集哦。
但其实不是，
我们后面要请小李。
跟我们讲一下，
他的那个职场，
理财大师课啦。
不要把我吹得这么高。
在开始前，
小李就说，不要轰托我，
是一个非常专家的人。
我们也没有做收费播客，
我们还不是免费跟大家分享吗？
哎呀，你更现实。
拉财。
总之啦，
先跟大家讲讲说，
我们是因为什么样的事情，
开始有了这样的心态转变。
我先来讲就是，
我以前一直觉得好像自己的收入，
会有一个相对，
不说突飞猛进吧，
还是会有一个比较持续的提升的。
大家也知道我那个。
跳槽经验相当丰富。
我基本上，
每年7月都会进入一家新的公司。
你是跳跳虎。
对。
我很好奇，
这件事情，
按理说，在HR看来，
你的简历就很花呀。
花的不能再花了。
但它巧舌如黄吧。
对呀，你巧舌如黄，
你还是能进入到下一家大厂。
哎，就是，
反正每年7月都在挥手，
跟旧的公司告别，
然后迎接新的朋友们。
但今年，
今年目前为止，
还没有啦，
我们尽管起遍吧。
也就是说呢，
意味着我基本上，
每年在这边预告，
自己有限私的喊话。
没有啦。
但反正基本上，
就是每年的，
因为7月份入职嘛，
所以每年6月都在经历一场，
跟HR的弹心之战。
我印象中，
前几年，
就是大家跳槽的时候，
都会讨论说，
你长了多少，
我拿多少的长幅。
一定要有30%啊。
这么高？
对呀，那时候如果，
你就说没有30%的长幅，
大家就会，
哈,
哎呀,
就说那你不要跳了，
30%都没有，
还不够你适应新环境，
跟你那个年终奖的损失的。
对呀。
而且那个时候，
去弹心的时候，
就是也会非常有信心的，
先抛出一个，
你知道40%左右的，
长幅数字，
让它砍一砍，
就是双方隔一遍，
彼此一切退路，
然后砍到30%的时候，
就洋装遗憾的，
就说，好吧，
那我给出了很大的诚意哦，
只是大家在30这里结束。
我还记得我第一次跳槽的时候，
那个时候，
那家公司的HR，
就是抱着非常抱歉的心情，
跟我说，
不好意思，
我们公司就是那个跳槽，
长幅,
真的就是卡30%，
但不过，
我们现在知道，
你现在的bass比较低，
我们去看一下，
给你走一下，
那个特殊申请，
能不能给你特批一个，
比如说35%这样。
哦,
当时我还说，
哦,35%,
好啊,
那就这样啊，
就勉强来吧。
勉强接受吧。
但是,
这几年不断的，
又不断的跳槽，
就跟那个小李刚刚说的，
我的简历真的是，
繁花四斤，
如同那个植物园一样，
非常的花，
我那个职业，
稳定性较差，
然后另外就是，
可能工资也长到了一定的水平，
就是在这个，
普通,
在这个专员级别里面，
就是已经，
也算是，
小有工资的水平了，
就是也不是，
也没有什么团队管理经验，
现在给不了你更高的工资了，
我就发现那个弹心，
现在又不如之前那么轻松了。
你现在如果再抛出，
30%这样的数字，
别人就会问你，
蛤?
别人就会想问你，
你看看外面是什么世道，
对啊,
你是不是疯了，
然后直到我这一份工作，
就是我之前不是，
gap了五个月嘛，
然后又是从一家，
所谓的数码公司，
跳到一个传统，
相对传统的制造业公司，
所以我的这个月bass，
其实从数字上来看，
只是涨了10%都不到，
然后如果再看总包的话，
基本上就是没有什么变化了，
因为前公司有很多加班费啊什么的，
所以基本上就是凭着跳过来，
然后再想一想，
在这个通货膨胀这么猛烈的时代，
如果你三年都没有涨薪，
你其实就相当于是降薪了，
因为钱没有以前值钱了，
所以展望我自己的这个职业生涯，
也不知道是ISFP还是ADHD在做，
又开始给自己找，
也可能是前二月受损吧，
开始怪标签啦，
又或者是皮脂唇过高呢，
还是说我身体里缺一些多巴胺，
缺一些饰黄唇，缺一些维生素，
ABCDFG,
你这样会让我们听众劝对，
说开始了，
播客主播开始寄出一些大词，
播客主播就爱说这些乱七八糟的，
找不到主体性了，
寻找人生主体性，
总之就是，
你们不知道你们怎么想，
就我越来越明确的感觉到那个，
所谓的35岁门槛，
35岁危机的到来，
因为人家都说，
你在大厂里面，
你想要活得好，
你也不说活得好，
你想要活下去，
就需要狼性，
需要你有这个，
所谓的主观能动性，
你要自己去找活，
你要给自己找事情做，
但是我觉得，
我的人生格言，
已经越来越变成，
如果一个东西，
需要我去争，去抢，
才给我，
我就不要了，
I quit,
但是这在智商里，
非常危险的，
没错,
就是,
我自己也不是，
不知道这一件事情，
但我觉得我就是，
心力焦脆，
我们不适合这个，
肉肉强食的世界，
对啊,
我实在是，
没有心力去给自己争取，
什么,
就是更多的机会，
跟更多的，
任务了，
我真的觉得，
对于现在的我来说，
我能够把这些，
交给我的事情，
按时按制的，
给它做完，
给它,
符合我自己的，
这个质量线，
给它做完交付出去，
我就已经耗尽全力了，
我真的觉得，
这个,
35岁危机，
就在前方，
我已经看到它，
露出它的额头了，
就在这里啊，
你看我34岁，
原地,
公司解散，
失业,
对啊,
我就想说，
过一两年，
我是不是要被这种，
所谓的大厂，
中厂淘汰了，
我可能现在就是我，
人生收入的巅峰了，
可能我以后，
不会再比现在，
赚得多了，
你判词，
下得太早了吧，
怎么办，
焦虑,
小柳还说，
35岁焦虑呢，
但我其实，
以我现在的观察，
可能,
什么28到31岁的人，
就可能你还不到35岁，
你就已经有，
很大的压力了，
天哪,
就说实话，
我刚开始概谱的时候，
真的,
没有这么焦虑，
也没有想到，
我会概谱这么久，
因为,
当时,
你刚离开前司，
你肯定是觉得，
正好趁这个机会，
好好休息，
瞧整一下，
再出发，
没错,
然后凭借我的工作，
经验和能力，
等我修养好了，
我重回这个就业市场，
我不说，
我现在就这样，
什么直级，
心思翻倍，
我至少能去，
比前司更好的平台吧，
你知道，
我一直觉得，
那个前司，
根本配不上我，
然后,
我一定会，
把前司，
更好的平台，
这样,
当然,
结果,
等我真的打开，
招聘软件，
看了一圈之后，
我发现，
哇,
真的,
现实给我当头一棒，
我自己，
还是太理想化了，
现实哪来那么棒，
天天对着我们，
头精准瞄准，
天天当头一棒，
真的,
现在的招聘市场，
跟咱们，
前几年，
找工作的时候，
真的,
完全不是一个生态，
以前觉得，
很理所当然的岗位，
然后现在，
那种岗位，
极少诶，
然后那个薪资，
就是离谱，
你就觉得，
是,
打折了吧，
是不是那个，
买三万，
减两万，
打了七折，
打了五折，
没错,
最近我刷到，
好多那种，
对比短视频，
比如说，
十年前，
你打印个简历过去，
人家就说，
哇，你会自己打印，
简历过来，
你是一个有准备的青年，
请入职，
十年后，
你就要做N个测试，
什么十面，
就不光是三面，
五年的，
十面都来了，
还是没有，
还要准备，
很丰富的作品籍，
和方案，
说我为你们公司，
发现了这样那样的问题，
然后我有这样那样的，
解决方案，
没错,
我想到小李，
上次说的，
然后,
以前,
你会看到，
有的JD,
你就会说，
这什么离谱的要求，
就是要求你，
什么,
单修,
大小舟，
或者是，
你要一个人，
有门的工作，
然后,
你当然是觉得，
啊,
谁要去做这种，
破工作，
然后你就发现，
有成百上千个，
履历非常漂亮的人，
在争抢这一份工作，
而且还比你便宜一半，
没错,
然后,
我刚才为什么说，
不到35岁，
你就感到危机了呢，
就是我们现在，
这个年龄的人，
可能,
已经在，
大厂,
或者头部公司，
工作了，
一定年数，
然后,
也有,
不错的履历，
也积累了，
一定的经验，
但是,
你到了这个阶段，
你就会发现，
你在,
自己的这个公司，
你往上升的话，
你头顶的，
岗位就那么几个，
你的晋升，
就是很难的，
但是你往外跳，
市场给出的薪资，
很难比现在高了，
以前我们会，
默认我们，
下一份工作，
就是刚才讲的，
一定会，
整个30%,
或者至少，
一份更好吧，
现在你会发现，
哇,
你就是，
保持住原来的，
薪资水平，
那你可能，
你要做的工作，
是比以前 double 的，
就是,
感觉用人当，
为了那个心态，
完全变了，
以前是，
要用更好的待遇，
来把你挖过来，
现在是，
我给你一份工作，
你就不错了，
你能赚到，
跟以前一样的钱，
外面多少人，
等着做呢，
你不知道吗，
对呀,
挤破了头，
来找这份工作呢，
就是,
大家的想法，
就是说，
啊,
我们努力工作，
我们一定会，
就是,
一直往上，
上好生活，
没错,
但后来发现，
哦,
好像我们的成长，
也有一些那个，
你知道，
时代红利，
在里面，
我们可能，
就是也赶上了，
一些什么互联网啊，
新媒体的，
快速发展期哦，
我们也是坐上了，
快速车，
跟那个电梯呢，
我们居然，
已经是，
吃过时代红利的人了吗，
吃过啊，
那个红利的尾巴，
然后现在发现，
就是这个红利的电梯，
它慢了下来，
我们是那个，
清了红利的尾单，
买了一点红利，
那个清仓尾货，
哎，是那个，
不管啥红利，
到我们这儿就，
就结束，
就44结束了，
对,
大环境，
到我们这儿，
就永远都变得不好，
我们还吃上了一个啊，
独生女的红利，
对呀,
也是尾巴呀，
所以我现在就感觉，
啊,
整个环境的增速，
都在放缓，
这台电梯，
它,
它不,
它不尽择退了，
有一点，
所以就是，
我们以前的薪资水平，
我现在就是觉得，
我能保持住，
就已经非常幸运了，
那 maybe,。
我可能就是，
要降薪，
去其他公司了，
哎呦,
大城市有大城市的焦虑，
我们小城市，
也有小城市的焦虑，
众所周知，
我是一个三年前，
从北京回到，
我老家，
上班的一个，
妈呀,
三十四岁女性，
已经在三十五的那边缘了，
然后,
之前在北京的时候呢，
我很大一部分的，
就是,
钱的焦虑，
就来源于房租，
因为刚工作那一会儿，
我借住在我北京，
西郊,
乡山的姑姑家，
我当时每天，
从西六环跑东三环，
通勤,
单程就是三个小时，
往返就是六个小时，
哇，真的身心俱疲，
妈呀,
后来我就想说，
这笔钱真的不能省，
我就用钱来换时间吧，
就开始租房子，
哦，从东五环，
搬到东四环，
再搬到东三环，
就陆陆续续地再搬，
基本也是每年搬一次吧，
然后通勤是越来越方便了，
但是我的房租也是逐年增加，
然后最夸张的是，
因为我做的行业，
它工资本身就很低嘛，
所以我的房租，
直接占了我工资的一半，
所以剩下的钱，
我就只能
我记得我刚去北京工作的时候，
我就跟自己说，房租，
千万不能超过工资的30%，
所以我一开始，
做的都是一些很烂的房子，
对呀，我也是啊，
四卧,
然后一套房子拆成，
四个卧室，
就客厅，
两个四卧那种，
你回到家里，
跟开party一样，
来大城市打拼的，
牛马都是这样啊，
租那种单间，
最烦的就是，
你室友是不可控的，
就你自己能保证你的一母三分地，
但是你的室友是什么样的，
你完全无法预估，
你还要跟他们共用卫生间，
没错,
反正在北京打拼那几年，
工资虽然长了，
但是长得很有限，
但是自己的年龄呢，
一年比一年大，
我觉得我的职场竞争力，
是一直在贬值的，
就在北京是非常贬值的，
我曾经也是满心期待说，
我要在北京混出点样子了，
你知道那种，
什么北京青年啦，
那个叫什么，
北京爱情故事啦，
那些东西看多了，
就觉得我，
几年内我就实现了这个，
层级飞跃，
你就要穿着那个职场套装，
拿着新马克咖啡，
在办公室里大大大大大大，
那样走，
然后没事去三里屯逛个街啦，
干嘛干嘛的，
但是,
现实就是不管怎么努力，
好像都在那个温宝线上，
大转,
距离中产这个目标，
太远了，
然后就回老家了嘛，
最大的变化，
就是没有房租压力了，
我的那个，
房产支出直接为0A，
然后,
然后我爸又给我买了车，
感谢老爸，
所以,
虽然现在的工资是，
比北京的时候低了不少的，
但是,
反而我这些钱，
都是可以自由支配的以后，
我的那个消费力，
反而是变高了，
因为你赚多少就花多少嘛，
天呐,
然后,
完蛋了，
妈呀,
你的生活太滋润了吧，
是啊,
但是就是在这个地方，
又没什么可消费的，
所以我就出门嘛，
追心啊，
我将在本期，
担任那个最大反派了，
不是反派，
反面暗力了，
反派,
你要打我们俩，
你要把我们俩，
一人一掌，
感觉要抢我们的钱那样子，
不是，反派是最后要被打的，
反正就是，
也是回了老家以后嘛，
这个,
大家都知道年纪增长呢，
遇到很大的一个问题，
就是你的，
父母年纪也在增长，
所以就是遇到了很多，
很现实的压力，
比如说我爸生病啊，
他要后期要长期的休养啊，
现在我就是要做一个，
一家之主嘛，
这个是我生活比较大的一个，
可以说是主线任务，
也可以说是焦虑的来源，
确实,
然后呢，
这个钱的方面，
其实压力还好，
因为我爸这些，
手术啊，
这些养兵的花费，
都他自己cover了，
再加上他有那个，
报销嘛，
他可以医保报销，
所以,
感谢国家，
就是报销的成本，
那个比例大概占了70%，
就是他的，
前面的一些费用，
而且我们家也没什么外债，
所以没什么，
生活方面的，
开销的压力，
然后我本来以为，
我这样已经是一个，
相对平稳的状态了嘛，
没想到，
我这连这点收入，
都没有了呢，
今天四月的时候，
不是,
我们公司直接就倒闭了嘛，
哎,
我这收入直接等于零，
还好还好，
其实还，
虽然看起来，
消费是一个那个，
无底洞一样的一个人，
但还是有存点存款的，
而且再加上，
平常我的生活开销，
是跟我爸一起分担的嘛，
我这个全职女儿，
就没有太大的一个，
经济压力，
所以,
哎，人到三十家，
我也想开了，
再不再奢求什么，
大富大贵，
飞黄腾达，
能稳稳地，
握住自己当下的一切，
这就是我最大的，
有人稳稳地，
拖住你，
稳稳地幸福，
很像那种，
视频号的那个，
花字文啊，
但确实是我，
真实的一个想法，
静待花开，
全职女儿也很好，
我要稳稳地幸福，
所以我发现，
我们到了三十岁之后，
我们赚的钱，
可能,
不会有很大的变化，
但我们花的钱，
可以分都没有变少哦，
我当时也觉得，
我买房是理性消费哦，
我们从小，
被灌输的那个，
理念,
这一定要有一套房，
这是你的资产啊，
对啊,
我先给大家，
讲讲我这个，
理性消费的故事吧，
当然,
这笔消费，
有点过于大宗哦，
大宗消费，
我相信，
我们的大多数，
听众朋友，
以我们听众朋友的，
平均年龄来看，
暂时还不会，
遇上我这个倒霉熊，
故事,
大家都知道，
我现在，
最大的一笔，
固定资产，
同时也是，
我最大的一笔，
固定资出，
就是我现在，
住的这个房子，
为什么会在北京，
买房子呢，
这不是每个人，
梦想的moment，
moment,
我觉得人，
千万不要有，
那个攀比心态，
因为我，
20年8月份的时候，
在第一份工作的公司，
就是落户了，
当时也是跟，
很多竞争者，
我们同台竞技，
最后拿到了，
这个珍贵的，
户口指标呢，
好棒耶，
然后落下了户了之后呢，
我妈就开始，
催我看房，
8月份落的户，
然后我妈就开始说，
赶紧去看房，
我现在想想，
她可能是为了，
替我在你知道，
婚恋市场，
获得一定的，
竞争资本，
对耶,
我觉得你如果，
换成是女生，
也不会这么，
急着去买房，
反正她当时，
非常火急火了的，
催我看房买房，
我当时，
自己根本，
没什么买房的想法，
然后我那会儿才多大，
那我才25岁，
然后上班才刚刚两年，
就是这个，
你别说买房了，
就是拿到，
北京户口这件事情来说，
对我来说，
都是一个，
天上掉了一个线饼，
就是那种意外知习，
更不要说买房了，
我那时候觉得，
在北京买房，
就是一个天方夜谈，
就是离我非常非常的远，
但是当时我的好朋友，
然后他也是我的老乡，
他当时比我早，
半年,
拿到了户口，
然后当时出于投资的考虑，
他也是拿了户口，
说没多久，
就在北京买了一套房，
而且,
就是买在旺京，
他买的房子面积，
比我当时买的，
第一套房子面积，
还要大，
他第一套房买了，
那些小区，
也比我后来买的小区，
要稍微新一点，
虽然也是老的小区，
但是稍微新一点，
零零年左右的小区，
天呐，那很贵吧，
他当时买房子可贵，
当时买下来560多万，
然后我当时跟他一起去看房，
我就了解了一下，
当时的北京方式，
你知道那个时候，
其实是，
疫情刚刚开始的时候，
然后看房其实挺不方便的，
就是进入小区，
都要拿那个通行证，
然后那个时候，
中介就非常的厉害，
就是他会帮你搞到，
搞定这些，
你知道出入小区的，
这些通行证，
然后让你带进去看房，
因为看房不方便，
所以那个时候房价，
相比之前，
有一点点回撤的迹象，
就是比19年最高峰的时候，
其实是要便宜一点的，
所以那个时候，
所有中介都在说，
哇，现在就是买房的好时候，
你等到这个疫情结束，
当然大家都觉得要去减漏啊，
对啊，你赶紧减漏吧，
等疫情结束，
房价肯定会火速又涨起来的，
那时候，
中介都是这么说的，
当时我们的想法就是，
房价就像火箭一样，
会一直往上猛冲，
你不管什么时候入场，
都是一个很好的时机，
对啊，没有人想过，
房子会怎么会大跌的，
从来没有人想过，
只会觉得说，
没有以前长的，
就是长的是很猛，
还长的比较平缓，
但是不会有人觉得说，
房子会跌价的，
所以在这样的，
这个社会情绪的撩动之下，
我爸妈，
在那一年的国庆，
10月1号准时落地北京，
10月5号,
4天之后的凌晨，
我们已经把买房的合同签了，
哇，你们家消费好迅速哦，
就做这种大宗消费的那个决策，
也太快了，
前后看了可能不到10套房子吧，
妈呀,
我现在想，
我不知道在急什么呀，
当然我觉得也有一个原因，
是因为我们预算就是，
也不高，就是有限，
所以我们都能看的房子，
也不多，
就你能看的房子，
你自己还看得上的房子，
也就是那种老婆小，
反正还是要说，
当时的那个社会心理，
就是赶紧上车，
你就是凡是有机会，
你只要上就对了，
对呀,
就是当时买的就是，
所谓的上车盘嘛，
就跟小李刚刚说的，
所谓的上车盘，
就是你赶紧加入这个房市，
你用相对有限的预算，
你能买到这个房子，
然后你就进入这个房市交易的，
你就上了这辆车了，
上了这辆高速轨道了，
因为我跟我爸妈都许那种，
我们不是特别在乎小区环境，
我相对比较在乎这个房子的地段的这个人，
你知道我妈当时看房，
最喜欢问的问题是什么吗？
她就喜欢跟中介问说，
这里离天安门有多远？
她就觉得，
在她的标准里面离天安门的，
对，她觉得离天安门的距离，
就是能够判定这套房子，
是不是在一个比较好的地段，
是不是在一个比较市中心的地方，
她就觉得说，
因为我们小城市，
所谓的市中心，
可能就是一个繁华地带，
最繁华的地方，
有一个标志性的建筑，
在它看来北京天安门最繁华的地方，
然后分散性的延伸，
离它近，
可能就是繁华的地方，
离它远，
可能就是乡下老，
她就这么想的，
但是她没有想过，
北京是一个分布式的，
这里有一块，那里有一块，
多中心的，
对，我们经常讲，
她不理解这一点，
所以当时，
我们买了四环边上的房子，
四环边上的这个小区，
当然我现在还是住这个小区，
这个房子，房领比我都大，
80，90年还是80几年的房子，
然后当时售价就400多万，
400多万的房本面积是61平，
哇，一平多少钱？
400多万是房子的裸价，
就是房子本身的价格，
你还要交中介费，
还要交税费，
那个时候中介费是。
两点多个点吗？
然后税费也比现在高，
一平轻松破7万，
我记得小柳跟我说的时候，
我觉得天文数字，
怎么会这么贵，
怎么会，我怎么会买了一套单价，
7万以上的房子，
当时我就觉得说，
不可思议，
所以我们一直称她为。
北京富豪的先生，
没有哪个富豪是住，
就是房本面积60平，
17面积40多平的房子的，
我现在讲，我都想哭了，
我不知道我那时候怎么活过来的，
我那个时候工资到手就是。
1万出头，
就是10到手工资1万出头，
然后刚开始的房贷就是1万块，
所以我每个月要还的房贷就是1万块，
你要怎么活啊，我请问，
我那个时候的工资，
加上工资金，
我才刚刚能够
cover我的房贷，
跟我自己的生活所需，
我工资金就是3千两块钱，
因为1万块钱，
所以我每个月就花了3千两块钱，
就要把我的吃穿住行全部cover住，
住是房贷了，
然后我当时工作了两年，
买房贷是工作了两年，
所以我那时候也是有几万块存款，
也是直接献给房贷，
一分钱都不剩，
全部交过去了，
所以就是也没有任何的存款可言，
那你就是月光了，
就是挣多少花多少？
纯月光，
甚至就会出现那种就是，
很有可能如果工资还不发的话，
我就要没钱了，
我手头就没钱的那种状态了，
不过后来我爸妈就是又掏出了一些积蓄，
帮我提前还了一笔带，
然后我的每个月的月贡才降到6-7千块钱，
但是依然还是非常的紧巴，
就是入不敷出，
所以我就很快地进行了第一次跳槽，
就是刚刚那个35%的那个跳槽，
然后回看这个房市，
一开始房市还是比较乐观的，
你知道我20年10月份买的房子，
我记得到21年年中的时候，
房子还是涨了一点钱的，
我买的时候是400出头，
然后到21年年中的时候，
它基本上已经到480块500了，
因为我那个房子就是，
刚刚讲的所谓的上车盘，
所以它交易需求是很大的，
因为它的总价相对来说比较低，
就很多想在北京落户成家的人，
他们也没有那么多钱，
他们就想买一个这种便宜的小房子，
先安下家来有自己住的地方，
所以房子还是涨过一点的，
但是我朋友刚刚说那个，
买了那个80多平的房子，
它涨的更多，
当时甚至有一度涨到过600多，
然后当时我还跟朋友就是窃喜说，
哇，我们这种普通人，
别学理财了，我们就买房吧，
买房就是我们普通人最好的投资手段，
对呀，这投入产出比太惊人了，
对呀，一年就涨了四五十万，
我们用固定资产，我们抵抗消费陷阱，
我们用房贷来克制强制，
我们用房贷来让自己强制储蓄，
克制那个消费的欲望，
好乐观好上行的一个年代哦，
没有想到过了半年之后，
因为疫情迟迟没有任何的好转的迹象，
就是大家的全国房市就开始。
一点一点的走向崩潭，
你就发现那个房子，
当然后面的故事，
就是大家都知道的故事了，
后面就是已经是大家了解的。
现在的现状，
那我的微观故事呢，
就是我的房子从开始的略涨一点，
跌回我买入的时候的买入价，
也就是不到半年嘛，
二二年初就跌回原本买的时候的价格了，
然后当时还觉得说，
哎呀一场梦啊，
但至少就是也还没有亏钱，
然后后来就开始一路下跌，
一路下跌，
就有一段时间我根本就不敢打开那个贝壳，
买房那个APP，
我根本就不看房市了，
就你每一次打开房市的那个APP，
你就会发现，
基本上每个月我们小区的平均成交价，
都已跌一千到两千的幅度，
在不断的下行，
每一平跌一千，
六十平，也就是说，
每个月我住在亏六万块钱，
然后直到二五年，
去年的时候，
我就发现，
如果我们小区跟我同户型的房子，
如果楼层稍微差一点的，
或者是朝向差一点的，
只能卖到250万了，
差一半，
就是腰斩了，
真的是结伴了，
我那个时候的心情就想说，
我这辈子能赚到250万吗？
但是你还在以之前的价格要还贷，
没错,
我还要以之前的价格去还贷，
去还这笔欠银行的钱，
就真的就是为银行打工，
所以那段时间有很多，
他们之前买在宴交，
买在那个什么，
三合的那些地方的人，
他们的房子很多是，
从300万跌到100万，
跌到50万，
他们就不还了，
真的就不还了，
那怎么办呢？
就是成为实行人，
成为老赖，
不还了，不管了，
因为没钱可还了，
还完了又怎么样了，
还完了就还，
他能够成交的价格，
只有50万了，
天呐,
时代的一例是，
放在我们普通人上，
又成大山了，
红利只吃到尾货，
那个一例杀，
怎么吃到那个最，
刚刚上心的，
完整版一例杀，
买一送一，
超大杯一例杀，
但是那个时候，
你知道跟我，
同时间进入职场的，
我的初代牛马朋友，
他有一天告诉我说，
他户头的存款，
已经破了百万，
我的妈呀，
他做了什么？
就是这几年，
我们的收入是差不多的，
但他因为没有买房，
然后他相对比较，
会攒钱，
然后又他，
因为他一直在谈恋爱，
他跟,
他跟两个人一起，
分担这个生活压力嘛，
所以整体就是，
支出就是会比较少，
对,
我当时听完之后，
我心情真的跟见了鬼一样，
我想说一百万，
哪来的一百万，
怎么一百万，
怎么跟，
是谁家狗的名字吗？
只不过你就是，
给银行了呀，
对,
我就开始算账，
我想说，
如果这些年，
我没有买这套房子，
我如果选择租房的话，
我现在存款大概是多少，
然后我现在，
我不仅没有这笔存款，
我还要承受这个房价，
猛跌,
带来的反评，
就是如果我当时，
没有这么急着买房子，
哪怕我现在还要买，
我现在拿着我这些年存的钱，
跟爸妈的这些存款，
一起再作为本金，
作为首付，
再来买房的话，
我该能买到多好的房子，
我的选择会有多大的范围，
我现在可能就住在一个地段，
相当优越，
有地下停车场，
人车分流，
我可以开车，
看到我们楼下，
一毛钱雨都不灵，
我可以过上这样，
梦被雨球的生活了呀，
我可以住在这2010年后，
建的小区里啦，
那你现在，
就是现在你推荐买房吗？
现在是买房的好时候吗？
我觉得，
要看,
依然不是，
当然不是啊，
但是我觉得，
投资市场就是这样，
你当然是做了你当下，
最正确的一个选择，
你现在是因为房价跌了，
所以你在这边抱怨说，
哎呦,
我的那个钱都给银行了，
但是如果还按照之前，
那个增速在涨呢，
你现在可就是，
千万级资产，
手握那个房，
没错,
你就觉得理财达人啊，
我就会跟他说，
赶紧上车买房，
买房永远都不完，
但是,
比如说，
小特现在，
你有一个刚需吗？
我觉得这个时候，
你是可以入场的，
你要看你自己的情况，
不是说，
我想,
我想抄底，
这就是，
一个不太好的理财，
投资观念，
而是说，
我很需要这个房子，
那你就去住，
然后你就也不看这个房产的，
涨跌,
因为你就是自住嘛，
最近很想这个，
有大型刚需，
想卖房，
置换,
不过因为现在这个房价跌了嘛，
所以就是，
我们之前节目里，
我也有讲到，
我就跟那个股民一样啊，
为了挽回损失，
我就补仓了，
我在去年的11月，
你听我们节目的，
应该知道，
去年11月，
我手套房正好，
就是买了5年，
因为满五，
就是可以在税收上面，
在那个，
购支税上面，
有一些折扣嘛，
然后我就选择了置换，
从老破小，
换到了同小区的老破中，
原本的那个房子，
400多买的，
最终以300万的价格出售，
然后补了，
补了30万的差价，
换到了我现在的房子，
还可以，还可以，
就是你只能这样安慰自己了，
因为这套房子，
如果我当年买房的时候买的话，
就可能要500多万嘛，
那我当时，
如果再加300万，
我是买30万，
我是买不到现在这个房子的，
相当于就是，
你好像那个数学体，
说小明花了多少万，
买了这个房子又卖出了，
然后又花了多少万，
买了一个大的，
现在请问他这套房子多少钱，
到底是亏了，
还是挣了，
算不没买，
里外里啦，
这个叫，
就是你只能这样安慰自己了，
就安慰自己减漏啦，
也不知道算不算减漏啦，
反正至少就是现在，
如果你不去想你损失的那个钱，
我现在对自己的居住环境，
还是相对比较满意的，
住在自己的房子里面还是很幸福啊，
对至少你就是不需要去搬家啦，
什么的，
但是我就是回头看我这五年，
就是关于买房这件事的整个过程，
就是从，
我感觉从我买第一套房，
签合同那一刻开始，
到现在，
我觉得几乎每一个决定都不是我自己做的，
我为什么会买第一套房，
因为我妈催我买房，
因为中介告诉我说现在是低点，
可以买了，
因为朋友已经买了，
然后整个这个情绪都弥漫在市场里面，
所有人都告诉你，
该买了，该买了，可以买了，
但是我好像，
回顾一下，
我有没有一秒钟停下来问过我自己，
我真的需要这套房子吗？
我真的准备好买房，
我准备好背上这么大一笔债务了吗？
好像没有，
就直觉得说，
能负担，那就买吧，
这就是当时的一个，
做出决策的当时的这个考虑，
就很简单，
而且还有就是买这种，
买房子这种大宗消费，
我觉得有个特别阴险的地方，
就是你会自己合理化自己的这个消费，
就跟小李刚刚讲的一样，
你买了房之后，
你就会不断的跟自己说，
这是刚需，这是投资，
这是在强制储蓄，
你买房了之后，
你就不会乱花钱了，
我当年就这么自己骗自己了，
结果呢，
我觉得这个强制储蓄是没有储道的，
但强制负债是十大十的，
每个月六七千的房贷，
就这么雷打不动的，
从我的这个银行账户里面扣走，
然后我工资长的速度，
是永远追不上这个成本的，
你现在还有房贷吗？
我现在有房贷，
我现在每个月还有，
三千多块钱的房贷，
以及我还有那个装修的消费贷，
所以就是，
还是有一笔六七千块钱的这个固定支出，
然后感觉我跳槽，
多次跳槽，
为什么跳槽跳的这么频繁，
就里面也有很大的部分原因就是，
我还是觉得钱不够用，
钱不够花，
我压力还是很大，
因为我可能没有办法，
让我在一家公司里面去，
很深耕，
很直捉地去，
追求在这家公司的长远的发展，
因为在公司里面跳槽，
在公司里面升值跟涨薪，
还是很难的嘛，
但是你，
你赶紧跳槽，
你就很快就可以获得很，
短期的一个升值加薪，
所以我就觉得说，
看似好像是用固定资产，
来比靠了这个消费陷阱，
但其实掉进了一个，
更大的消费陷阱里面，
但是偶尔，
就是人家我们席反思人格，
就会在自己站在不同的立场，
去想这个问题。
如果我没有买这个房，
我也担心，
如果我没有买这套房，
这些钱我真的存下来了吗？
那就是一路的酸甜苦辣，
都可以在你身上，
本人身上体现呢？
就是如果我这么不懂理财，
然后就跟刚刚讲的，
总是苟苟苟花了，
不少大钱的这种性格，
我会不会连这套房都没捞下呢？
是啊,
对哦，也算强制储蓄了啦。
不断的反思，
不断的那个左右横飘。
刚刚小柳说的时候，
我就感觉，
这是在点我吗？
我没房，
我也没存下钱。
你看。
就是,
刚刚不是说，
你说有各种什么，
ADHD的问题啊，
什么多巴胺的问题啊，
我现在在想，
是不是原生家庭的问题？
道出怪。
道出怪？
走到找一个人怪吧。
我们在人生，
总要有一个冤大头来，
替我们那个，
缓解我们的原因呢？
我来听听，
你到底是什么角度，
才能怪到原生家庭？
人穷就会话多，
我们来反思一下自己，
为什么？
没有存下来钱。
就我们的心自问啊，
我们全家就是非常朴实的那种，
家庭,
就是既不会赚钱，
也不会理财。
我爸妈都是很普通的那种，
公心结层嘛，
他们从小就非常亲近结约，
你们应该知道，
就那一代人，
他们从小就会叫一喊，
说他不能乱花钱。
要踏实？
对，就是我们要结约，
就比如说水龙头啊，
这种,
你时刻得关灯，
你时刻得关好水龙头，
就那种小事上面，
都会很结约，
但是与此同时，
我们也没存下来钱。
听出来啦，
你不是什么，
上高中的时候，
就会去外地过年的那种家庭吗？
也是,
爱体验消费啦。
高中的时候，
每周末，
我们就会去吃一下大餐呐。
就说，这周辛苦了。
喜欢,
好,
他真的很擅长消费耶。
哦，那个，
靠赏自己。
反正,
我家一方面的消费，
大头就是我本人嘛，
从小到大，
这么多的，
教育成本花费。
然后另一方面呢，
也是我爸妈，
就是为各路亲戚，
不计成本的付出。
就是，那天，
那天我写稿的时候，
我才发现，
原来这不是我普遍现象，
我以为大家都这样呢。
你们家是那个装超音。
对呀。
结果你们都不是吗？
因为,
我爸妈是他们，
各自家庭里，
众多孩子，
闯出来的，
新城市一代嘛。
就家里都是，
从草原来到，
成分的。
对，就过来了。
然后,
所以他们对于，
没有出来的亲戚，
老家的亲戚，
有着超强的责任感。
笑装来了，笑装来了。
就是有任何的，
需求都满足，
有任何的借钱呢，
什么什么的，
都都都，
都会,
供养家庭。
我就反胜美嘛，
类似那样的一个感觉。
所以我从小看着以后，
我心里就，
可能埋下了一个潜意识，
就说,
如果以后要花钱，
我要尽量花在我自己身上。
我要做一个自私的人。
不要去做慈善了，
对自己好一点。
因为你，
那些付出，
真的很多，
但是都没有什么，
能够返回，
那还不如去投资了，
还不如去买房了，
还能看得到，
这些储存，
扔出去了，
根本看一看不见。
你们是怎么个，
资助法呢？
就是今天这家来借钱，
明天那家来借钱，
那其实借钱，
就是要钱，
对吧，他不会还吧？
对呀,
就几年后，
你在提这个事，
或者是我爸妈，
他压根就不会提嘛，
觉得还不好意思了，
看他也不容易，
什么的。
你爸妈都是长子，
长女吗？
不是。
哦，还甚至还不是？
不是啊，
就是家里面，
混的最好的孩子，
最有出息的孩子，
是的,
我爸甚至是忙内类，
我妈是比较中间的孩子，
我觉得可能我们的家庭，
我不知道小李家怎么样，
就是我爸妈，
他们都是三兄弟，
三姐妹，
就是都差不多，
大家过得都差不多，
没有谁比别人，
过得好特别多，
也没有谁过得，
比别人差特别多。
我爸妈是那个，
工薪阶层，
就是正死工资嘛，
但是他们的兄弟姐妹，
就是,
你们也知道东北会下岗，
然后所以下岗的时候，
他们都去做生意了，
那做生意，
就是会比我们这种，
工薪家庭，
正得多呀。
哦,
轮不上你来自助他们？
没错,
从小都是，
什么小姨呀，
姑姑啊，
给我买东西，
我是那个，
呃,
被绑出的，
被汇集的一方啦。
哦,
反正我们家，
我也不懂了，
就是一些很复杂的原因，
反正就是经常有，
之前有一些讲过嘛，
还经常来我们家，
吵架了，
很多家庭的矛盾了，
反正我就觉得，
哎,
我,
如果能花钱，
我就花在我自己身上，
所以从我自己能掌握，
这个花钱的权利以后，
我就会，
在我的生活成本上省钱，
因为这是从小养成的习惯嘛，
就是,
在买衣服啊，
我也不怎么买衣服，
也不买手势，
就这种，
包包啊，
这一类的，
就不打扮自己，
买吃的买喝的，
倒是常买了，
但是也不是那种说，
我炖炖鲍鱼海鲜的那一种，
就是,
吃个麻辣烫，
你说也，
撑不上什么大吃大喝，
喝杯小雪，
对,喝,
喝杯奶茶，
就是这个程度，
但是,
coco說說的，
花了很多大钱，
就是在这个精神消费，
文化消费上，
就是追星，
来了,
对啊,
就是,
在我个人的概念里，
吃吃喝喝，
都是身外之物，
穿啥衣服都能活，
但是追星的快乐，
是即时的，
是不会再来的，
就像你小时候，
没玩的那个玩具，
你长大了，
你就算有钱买了，
但你也不想玩了，
好会劝自己花钱啊，
你宴请了，
童年的自己，
不觉得很多人说，
宴请童年的自己吗，
但其实那个时候，
长大了，
你反而吃不了那么多辣条，
你也,
吃不了，
玩不了那么多玩具了，
就是,
如果你那个时候，
很喜欢一个什么东西啊，
我就,
我觉得我要去看，
我要去那个，
花钱,
你也不想想，
你喜欢的有多少，
喜欢的东西也太多了吧，
所以就说，
我们这么多年，
追星的墙头，
换了一波又一波，
不变的，
是我的消费，
三天,
三天一小请，
五天一大请，
每天都在宴请，
哎，但是比如说，
那个,
你追的那个，
他代言了很多产品，
我会在，
我购买的那个，
你叫什么，
品类上，
稍微选择一下，
比如说他代言了，
洗发水，
洗发水能用吗，
我就买嘛，
洗衣液，
这种就买嘛，
但是如果你要，
他代言一些什么，
花花草草，
也买不起，
你说跟我代言也没有什么关系，
这其中还有一些理性，
对,
我会在这中间买一些，
我能用到的，
主要是消费能力的限制，
反正就是一些，
贵平台就不会买了，
那请问你，
为了汪顺花了多少钱，
这几年，
看了好多好多的游泳比赛，
我就算不清楚了，
所以我说，
哎呀,
算一次最近去的一次吧，
令我震惊，
这不是六月份，
六月十五号到六月二十二号，
去了一个星期嘛，
这不赶上我也没工作嘛，
这不是正好嘛，对吧，
什么东西正好啊，
没工作不应该在家里吃康吗，
正好我也没收入，
不如我就多花点，
不是不如我就多待几天啊，
就是按理来说，
我不是，
大概一两天也就可以了嘛，
后来想，
反正都去了，
那你住五天，
住六天也是住啊，
那住两天也是住啊，
我们这，
就那么远过去了，
你机票的成本要用上对吧，
对啊,
然后就，
你说,
你看我来给你算一下细账啊，
比如说，
火耗头到杭州的王返机票是多少呢，
2164,
嗯，很便宜吧，
才2000嘛,
这还是我货比三家的，
如果高铁呢，
高铁的话，
还要去北京周转嘛，
然后时间会更长，
可能有一两天的时间都在路上了，
你现在不就应该以时间，
换金钱嘛，
哎呀，当当着着急嘛，
着急,
然后酒店呢，
哎，我克制京大戏算，
选了很便宜的一家酒店嘞，
七个晚上才1513元，
平均下来一天才200多，
200出头吧，
是不贵啦，
是不是，
在杭州哎，
住清旅的我说什么了，
他不行，
他要验请，
哪有验请，
在清旅验请，
不是，清旅实在是，
我有点不习惯跟陌生人同住啦，
还是想要一个自己独立的空间，
好，这都是小事，
接着往下说，
来，然后门票，
哎，六天呢，
六天上午决赛，
晚上,
上午预赛，
晚上决赛，
一天就两场对不对，
那六天一共十二场，
十二场总计，
门票哦，
三千五百八，
天呐,
我才知道，
原来牛油门票这么贵啊，
我们帮你抢了很多次票，
但是我记得每次，
都什么八十一百二的，
对啊，你们抢的都是便宜的啊，
特别抢票的时候，
都是不计成本的，
他就说你们去抢，
你们随便抢，
就抢最贵的，
哎，朋友们，
在这里我要跟那个，
我们全网的听，
给我们来分享一下，
是不是抢票之前，
你想了很多，
我要做哪个座位，
那哪个座位，
但你当你点开软件的时候，
哪儿有空坐点哪儿，不是吗，
有空坐就赶紧点呐，
当然不是啊，
一千五百八有空坐，
我不点啊，
我就不吃了，
有票就不错了，
还挑什么呀，
所以当时就抱着这样的心，
还有两场，
我是抱着说，
我一定要坐在前排，
因为这两场很关键，
是重要的比赛，
其他的我就坐在后面，
一出神土的，
对，后面的，
集场那种比较小的比赛，
我就坐在什么，
八十一百八的那个，
最上面的，
看台就好啊，
等一下，等一下，
人家要坐前排，
是说人家是占捷，
人家要拍土，
然后否自己的粉丝，
或者否自己未来的事业，
你非要坐在前排的理由是，
看得近呐，
这还用说吗，
你准备个望远镜吧，
望远镜没有用，
我有用过，
我还买过望远镜呢，
你看望远镜的钱也花了，
对呀,
哎,
用过望远镜的朋友，
可能会知道，
距离太远以后，
你手部稍微的抖动，
都会导致你的画面，
有一个大幅度的，
他们看那个游泳比赛，
没办法用望远镜了，
其实挺晕的，
说实话，
你那个移动的幅度，
你不如你肉眼看一会，
对呀,
他游泳比赛，
是在原地比的太后，
一幌子就冲出去30米了，
你要跟他早就丢了，
在水里都找不见人，
结束了，
都是理由了，
哎，然后再算一些，
七七八八的，
比如说一天吃饭，交通啊，
就大约算嘛，
一百块一天，
就是七百块嘛，
总计,
哎,
不到八千哦，
七千九百，
七千九百左右了，
这就是我七天的花费，
诶，平均到每一天，
也就是一千多一点，
你别平均，
你一个礼拜就花八千块，
你还想干啥呀？
而且去的是杭州，
公司有这么高吗？
人有些人去日本，
去一礼拜也就花八千，
真的假的？
有心的话，
他夸着，
总之啊，
就是,
我发现我自己的一个毛病，
是我每次看的都是单价，
但是当我这样，
把他整个算在一起的时候，
我发现，
哇,
确实挺贵的，
我自己也没有想到，
因为我每次只看，
那刚刚我就说，
哦，酒店还可以吗？
诶，看那个机票也还可以吗？
吃饭也还可以吗？
每次就觉得这样，
好像是一个小数目，
原来我花的不是单价，
我花的是总价，
这就是我没存款的原因呢，
如果我这些钱，
我都存下来，
我现在不说，
月入存款百万吧，
二十万应该有了吧，
二十万啊，
这么多，
这就是这么多年嘛，
大概一个饭值，
我不知道了，
一个礼拜就能存下八千，
对呀,
诶,
所以追星这件事情呢，
我其实还是不后悔的，
但我后悔的是，
从来没有人教过我说，
快乐和安全感可以同时兼顾，
我一直以为，
他们是对立的，
就是,
要么我现在有开心，
要么我未来有保障，
我有种月光族的那个概念，
但是,
我现在在想，
这个岁数也大了，
年纪也健长，
必须得学会
把钱分成几份，
比如说，
一份给现在的快乐，
一份给未来的自己，
诶,
问题在于没有人教过我了，
我们都是即时行乐的家庭，
大师来了，
请大师客给我们进行教你，
怎么那个分成几分？
大师也要先唱回了，
大师也失手吗？
虽然,
没有付出什么买房的支出，
跟那个追星的消费，
而且,
大家都知道我是金牛做马，
我一直觉得，
诶,
自己好像在理财上，
还挺有数，
挺稳重一人，
一小孩，
一孩子，
诶,
然后,
日常花钱也挺省的呀，
但是我发现，
哇,
股票绝对是这个世界上，
最极致的人性试炼场，
我们每个人都有一个结，
有花钱的地儿，
不是说嘛，
那个诈骗集团，
总能找到你的弱点，
去花钱，
对,
定制片局，
那我的定制，
可能就是，
这个,
投资市场啦，
因为你知道，
前一阵，
那个,
股票,
科技呀，
AI概念,
大火的时候，
每天打开社交软件，
首页全都在晒收益，
哇,
就是,
这个人股票翻倍，
那个人基金涨停，
就是,
我们标签那期说过啊，
FOMO的那个焦虑感，
就开始笼罩我了，
我是不是错过，
这次机会了？
没错,
我就觉得，
全世界都在发财，
只有我一个人，
站在原地，
就是,
我怎么没入场啊，
我也要进去啊，
就像,
那个小柳投身，
我要上车，
房产,
这就是环境的影响吧，
没错,
我也要，
走上这一波，
科技的快速路，
快速车，
真的是环境，
像,
我每天泡在那个粉丝群里，
大家都在晒自己的那个消费单啊，
你有为你的偶爸花了多少钱，
你好意思说你没花吗？
FOMO订单上面，
还要把自己的ID放到去做水印，
对啊,
我们每个人都有自己，
要上的车哎，
尤其是，
当,
整个时代，
都是这种，
情绪的时候，
你根本不可能理性，
你就像小柳上那个房产车一样，
你就是觉得，
你也得赶紧，
买一些那个科技方面的基金，
你也得赶紧买AI方面的股票，
你只要进去，
你就一定会涨，
就是因为害怕错过，
所以你就是，
根本就没有好好分析，
各种标的啊，
各种公司的财报啊，
你就是只要有机会，
你就,
一头扎进那个过热的股票市场，
哇,
进了场，
你才发现，
噩梦开始了，
就是首先，
上涨的时候，
你就是每天看到那个，
动不动10个点的收益，
你就觉得，
哇,
我是股神，
巴菲特不过如此啊，
结果,
你涨的时候，
你肯定不会落代为啊，
你就觉得，
才10个点，
我肯定能挣，
20个点,
30个点啊，
我要翻杯，
然后你就会还开始计算说，
哎,
我才投了1万块，
我才挣了1000呢，
你说我要是，
投个100万，
我是不是就能挣10万了，
我这一天，
就能挣10万，
我,
我还想什么办，
真的,
所以你就开始后悔说，
我早知道，
我砸过卖铁，
我挣点钱，
我集资，
我多卖一点啊，
你就好想夹藏，
你淡散有点钱，
你都想投入进去，
哇,
结果,
等到了下跌的时候，
你知道那个，
我们韭菜那种，
自我催眠的机制，
又开始，
启动了，
你就觉得，
才跌5个点嘛，
他肯定会涨回来的，
所以,
就是,
只要我不卖出，
我就没有跌，
记住性回调，
没错,
你就死扛啊，
输不知，
就是,
市场的一个周期，
他可能就是几年呢，
就是,
牛市跟熊市的，
你看起来是两个市场，
那其中是多少个人的10年，
多少个人的20年，
也历沙又来了，
没错,
那本金，
就死死的，
被套在里面，
然后,
你就只是纸面的那个，
曾经有过的，
帐面富贵，
你,
其实什么都没有得到，
真可怕，
而且更疯狂的是，
我还不知死活的，
上过杠杆，
天啊,
就是一个，
非常可怕的事情，
说实话，
我一开始，
对杠杆的，
理解,
特别浅，
我就是觉得，
就像刚才说的，
假如,
我有10万块钱，
本金,
然后,
我,
加4个杠杆，
我就有40万了，
就是如果，
长10%的话，
我一下子，
就能长4倍，
就多长4倍，
我,
我当然是要，
you know,。
借这个钱啦，
我撬动，
给我一个支点，
我就能撬动，
这笔财富，
没错,
而且我是古神内，
我巴菲透，
当然就是，
能快速地挣到，
一笔大钱，
然后我就立马，
撤出来，
能还上补就好了吗？
但是,
输不知哦，
就是,
那都是上涨的时候，
股市有涨跌，
大家都是知道的吧，
等到下跌的时候，
哇,
你那个情绪，
就像那个，
绑定了那个K线一样，
你的恐惧，
放大了一万倍，
我的心率，
直接跟它绑定，
我才发现，
哇,
原来,
就是上杠杆，
是这么恐怖的一件事情，
因为你如果，
不上杠杆的话，
你,
我不去看那个，
K线就可以了，
就,
反正我也不会，
就是只要我不卖，
我就没有损失嘛，
但是输不知哦，
上杠杆的话，
它有一个，
怎么说，
机制叫平仓，
嗯,
就是当你，
四十万的仓位投进去，
然后股票市场，
跌了百分之二十五的时候，
哎,
现在这个股票市场，
跌百分之二十五，
很正常哎，
对啊,
如果你，
只是用自己手头的，
十万块，
跌百分之二十五的话，
你只是变成了，
七万五嘛，
就是,
你死撑一下，
还能扛，
但是,
当你上了，
四倍杠杆的时候，
四十万，
跌了百分之二十五，
就相当于，
你的十万块钱，
直接归零了，
是爆仓了，
然后,
那个软件，
就会直接帮你，
把全部东西卖出，
你,
你的钱，
就蒸发了哎，
就变成零了，
没错,
所以为什么，
有很多人，
像韩国人，
或者上了杠杆之后，
叫都睡不好的，
就是因为，
他要时时刻刻，
看着那个，
K线,
看着那个市场，
因为,
你很担心，
一个下跌，
你就爆仓了，
你这个整个人，
就破产了哎，
真的就是，
赌徒心态啊，
很恐怖，
我想问一个，
外行问题，
所以上杠杆，
不是说，
你实际把那个十万，
你再投了三十万，
变成四十万，
是在那个，
软件还是什么，
系统里操作，
显示说，
加杠杆，
这样一个操作，
是吗?
相当于，
你可以，
跟平台借这个钱，
去操作，
哦,
这个意思，
哦，明白了，
学习了，
比如说，
做空舱也是，
做空舱，
你要先卖出，
你可以，
没有底舱，
但是,
我可以先卖出，
然后再卖入，
反正就是一个，
须你操作的，
这么一个问题，
哦，那确实很容易，
出现问题，
有很多人，
上杠杆，
是那种，
去借,
就是去其他借贷平台，
借钱,
这也是一种上杠杆，
哦,
反正总之，
经历过那一次，
我就觉得，
哇，我这种，
谨慎的人，
我,
我的小心脏，
实在是受不了，
上杠杆，
这件事情，
太可怕了，
没错,
然后我就觉得，
相比于那种，
一夜报复的幻想，
就是,
我用杠杆，
我用,
几倍的资金，
去操纵，
我的那个，
股市,
我来挣到，
更多的钱，
就相比于，
这种一夜报复，
我们普通人，
还是,
宝本吧，
还是能兜底的，
理财才是，
最重要的，
我们要，
闻,
闻的幸福，
那,
什么叫，
能兜底的理财，
比如说，
大额存单，
或者是说，
一些财富保险，
我们应该以前，
也有听过吧，
就像我妈前几年，
也有买过，
一份那种财富险，
当时的利率，
大概就是两个点，
多一点，
哇，我当时，
还瞧不起来，
我想说，
才两个点，
哎，拜托，
我,
分分钟，
在股票市场，
三个点，
很小轻松，
运筹维吾一下，
没错,
结果,
你才怎么知道，
风水轮流转呢，
哎，现在大家，
赶紧打开你们的，
支付宝，
看一下那个，
我的利率，
那个七日年化，
现在直接就是，
一个点左右，
鱼额宝，
现在真的很夸张，
我记得鱼额宝，
刚出来的时候，
一块钱一天，
一块钱是轻轻松松的，
好的时候，
都一块二一块三，
现在鱼额宝，
现在放在里面，
就是两毛三毛，
因为那个时候，
利率就是很高啊，
你现在不光是鱼额宝，
你去那个，
银行的存款利率，
也都是一路下调的，
就这种货币基金的，
利率都是非常低的，
所以你反而看我妈，
当年,
就锁定了那个，
两个多点的，
保本收益，
而且有的人，
是在三个点的时候，
就,
就买这个保本，
就是你，
就会一直保持，
这三个点的收益，
哇，你现在在看这两个点，
三个点，
是神仙理财耶，
因为你现在的市场上，
根本就找不到，
这么高的收益的，
稳稳的幸福了，
那讲到这里，
我们就赶紧让小李，
给我们进行一下，
那个理财资讯吧，
我们来讲讲，
自己的那个，
我们给自己兜底的，
这些手段的方式，
快来快来，
我们到底是怎么，
在做储蓄跟理财的，
当然现在，
因为只有我一个人，
有收入，
那我就先抢了，
另外两位，
都是在用手头的钱，
在钱生钱，
我还是有一些，
净账啦，
就是但是我这个人呢，
又是实在是，
没有什么理财头脑，
不妨跟大家透露一下，
本人高考数学考了，
89分,
我看到那些什么，
比利,
利率我头痛，
我头大，
但是我又觉得说，
钱放在活期里，
躺着太亏了，
我总是要找一个，
定期存钱的途径，
一方面就是，
也获得一些收入，
一方面也让自己的钱，
不要在活期里，
有时候就被自己，
不知不觉的花掉了，
所以我现在，
只有一个存款方式，
就是这些，
银行APP,
或者是支付APP里面，
都有定头吗，
有基金定头，
我设置了一笔，
每天的自动定头，
然后它在每一个交易日，
都会,
帮我,
买入同一款基金，
它设置的是那个，
买多少交易额的，
那个定头，
就是我，
一天五十，
比如说，
一天五百，
当这个基金，
长起来的时候，
你今天能买的那个，
分数就少，
但相对来说，
基金跌下去的时候，
你今天能买到的，
分数就比较多，
那通过这样的方式，
你就可以，
相对的，
去拉平那个，
也是一种补仓嘛，
然后我现在，
就是,
唯一的一个，
理财方式，
我每个月，
过一日加起来的，
定头金额，
大概占了我，
税后收入的，
百分之四十左右，
那很高诶，
那,
那要看你买的，
基金是什么诶，
你要买，
你买的是那个，
其实风险还蛮大的，
我买的是，
纳斯达克的，
指数,
EPF,
OMG,
那波动还蛮大，
波动还蛮大的，
转的时候，
你会想说，
美国科技，
那个公司，
我为你们鼓掌，
我为你加油，
亏的时候，
我想说，
我爱你，
总之啦，
就目前看上去，
就是一个，
不亏不赚，
有时候赚一点，
有时候亏一点，
大概就是，
还比较平稳的，
这么一个状态，
然后另外百分之三十，
就是拿来还，
我的刚刚说的，
呃,
房贷跟装修贷，
然后剩下百分之三十，
大概就是，
我日常的生活开销，
我觉得，
听上去，
是不是还比较有纪律性，
就是,
好歹有分成，
分成三块钱，
然后,
都有定期的在储蓄，
而且有百分之四十的储蓄率，
我觉得，
已经算是，
都跟稳健的水平了，
你这百分之四十，
不是储蓄率哦，
你不要欺骗大家，
那是什么？
你放入纳斯达克，
是投资市场，
你就不一定，
涨还是跌呢，
你就不是稳稳的幸福哦，
不稳吗，
怎么办？
你这笔钱，
是算在投资了，
不是,
不是储蓄哦，
而且除此之外呢，
就是那百分之三十，
的生活费，
有时候，
其实不够花了，
就是,
会超值，
会做假价，
就是,
我有的时候，
会惊奇的发现，
已经上了好几个月班了哦，
因为我本来，
就对数字不敏感，
我看那个存款，
有时候看不出来自己，
这个钱有没有变多，
就是,
我这几个月都在上班，
然后也有工资进账，
但是总存款，
怎么好像差不多啊，
就是,
你看那个账面上，
好像分配的，
很明白，
但是我根本就是，
不记啊，
你们，你们不记账吗？
他们就不记，
我大概会知道，
自己一个月花了多少钱，
但是我记不住我自己，
你是每一笔都记吗？
我稍后会，
给大家讲我的那个，
理财理念，
学习一下，
对，反正我的话就是，
我如果，
我会觉得，
我每个月生活水平，
是差不多的，
但是比如说，
这个月，
比如说我上个月，
买了那个相机，
或者是我这个月，
有朋友结婚，
我要随分子，
或者是我这个月，
我觉得，
哦,
最近show the managing evil,。
然后就是钱一花，
那个弹性空间，
就被吃掉了，
其实根本就没有存到钱，
这个月反而，
钱变少了，
或者说钱没有变少，
但是没有存到钱，
钱就是变少了嘛，
而且就像小李刚刚讲的，
那个基金定投，
就是他是有浮动的，
所以他，
确实不是，
一个稳定的，
储蓄跟，
存钱的这么一个，
手段,
所以我想说，
这个配比，
是不是还是要去优化一下，
而且,
最近也听说自己，
你知道年到三十，
是不是也要去配置一些，
几显啊，
或者是财富显，
这样的一些，
其他的手段，
能让自己更加的，
有所谓的兜迪可言，
当然了，
我跟小柳，
其实有很大一部分，
是类似的，
就是我们不会记账，
我们没有那个，
理财的规划，
我也是那种，
很怕自己，
全花掉，
所以我就，
画出一部分，
小小的存款，
去放到银行的，
我比你那个，
风险还低了，
我就放那个，
整存整取，
就那种，
纯纯的定期，
他的那个，
很小嘛，
就刚刚说的可能，
原来是二，
最近已经是一了，
的那个程度，
那你放多久啊？
那种三年五年的那种，
三年五年才一啊，
现在开始了，
现在开始是一了，
原来,
曾经有，
很好很好的时候，
有什么2.93的时候，
所以那，
时间还没到，
再往下看，
这就变一了，
就直接钱出来之后，
再进入下一次存款的时候，
就要变成一了，
对，现在还没到一嘛，
你研究一下吧，
研究这个高的，
是嘛，快，
老师,
一放放三年的，
不可能这么低啊，
好的,
这个太，
太太低了，
好的,
我们就是不会研究，
我就研究这些东西，
真的很头疼，
我每次就很想说，
请用最直观，
最不绕弯子的告诉我，
放这儿能赚多少，
挣钱的事情，
就是你要自己去，
研究就要花心死啊，
这是你自己的钱呢，
能不能告诉我，
你们银行，
现在最好的那个，
理财产品是什么，
两万块钱进去三年后，
能不能变成两万三？
对,
我只想要这样的一个东西，
就是我们不会理财的人，
就是这样子，
然后还有一部分，
其实有点跟小柳差不多了，
就是,
用鱼吃喝玩乐是一部分，
还有一块就是，
留给我那不争气的快乐，
追星,
就是小柳要不忙墓一些的一部分，
刚才也提到了，
我是全之女儿嘛，
你原来更没法算账的原因，
是因为，
有很多混在一起的账目了，
像,
买家里的持传用度的东西，
我发现，
开始管家有，
要用的东西很多，
对呀,
明明听过有个短视频吗，
就是,
夫妻两个，
就经常因为这种事情吵架嘛，
就是,
丈夫没有意识到，
其实,
花心思为家里买东西，
是一个很，
琐碎,
但是又费事的功夫，
然后评论说，
要不有个岗位叫采购的，
就是因为采购是很需要的心思，
在做的业务，
家庭精神投入，
对对对，
然后这部分，
我也就属于一个，
比较混沌的一个状态，
反正总之，
随着年纪增长以后，
我发现了，
不规划理财，
抗风险能力，
就是纸糊的，
我虽然没什么大剑的购物，
每天吃吃喝喝的，
但是,
养老啊，
治病啊，
那是早晚要敲门的债主，
就理财就很像一个，
我一直躲一直躲，
但是他一直迎面，
撞上来的课题，
就我很想把他拖拖拖，
但现在好像有点，
躲不掉了，
也赖不掉了，
我只能迎着头皮去面对，
仙女下凡来解答，
大师上线，
因为我现在，
处于那个，
没收入阶段嘛，
然后,
应该很多人都会疑惑，
说你不上班，
心里不会发慌嘛，
但是说实话，
我其实在上班的时候，
就非常有意识的，
在为自己存这一笔，
f**k you ma,。
你,
诶，伯可可以讲，
要打马嘛，
必有万里，
f**k you,。
总之了，
就是,
一笔足够让你在任何时候，
都能对不喜欢的工作，
不喜欢的生活，
say no,
说去你的老子不干了的，
这么一笔自由的，
资金,
那我的方法，
就是在概谱之前，
我每个月都会在固定的时间，
去统计我的总资产，
虽然我叫，
家庭总收，
总支出，
但家庭里面，
就只有我一个人了，
没有,
也没有特特那么复杂，
我一般都会是在，
每个月发完工资，
然后还完信用卡之后，
来统计我的余额，
然后包括各个渠道的，
不管是投资的，
还是说我的，
银行卡里面的，
然后股票市场里面的，
那你会算就是，
花费在哪部分，
因为现在很多APP，
都会帮你算一下嘛，
比如说，
用在吃喝上是多少钱，
用在什么上是多少钱，
你会算这个吗？
这个,
后面我会讲，
因为我已经，
记账记了很多年，
所以我对我自己的整体，
消费是非常清楚的，
我不需要再记那么细了，
因为我已经有我自己的，
一套,
你要说ISOP，
我活得好混沌啊，
那总之，
反正我就是要，
确保我存下的，
这一笔钱，
就算在我没有，
一分钱收入的情况下，
也要足够支持，
我稳稳当当，
不上班生活好几年，
我觉得这就是我的，
像护身服一样的钱，
给我稳稳的安全感，
那这一笔钱，
我的分配理念是，
很明确的，
第一块就是，
稳健,
就这一笔钱，
我绝对不会拿去，
冒任何的风险，
一定要确保它的流动性，
就是在我需要钱的时候，
我一定要可以，
立刻从我的银行卡里面，
转出来，
而不是说，
哎呀，我这笔理财还没到期，
我现在身无分文，
我,
没有办法还，
一笔什么的花贝之类的，
就是我要把它安安心心的，
放在各个银行的，
这个低风险的，
雇收理财里面，
然后,
我最大的乐趣，
我真的不懂你们那，
我非常喜欢去对比，
各个银行，
各个理财产品的利率，
不看了头大吗？
我就是喜欢这个数字，
我,
我对钱，
很有可报，
能让我钱，
变更多的东西，
我当然就是，
要花所有的精力，
投入在这上面呢？
就是我如果看到，
A银行是2.17，
B银行是2.27，
我就想说，
哎，算了吧，
我懒得动了，
就这样嘛，
那比如说，
B银行,
它有一个产品，
是2.58,
但是你每天，
要在当天的10点，
抢这个份额，
那我一定要，
上好闹表去抢，
每天,
就是你在需要，
购买这一笔，
自己那个，
理财的时候，
我只会抢票，
订到我中了，
所以,
我,
我的钱，
其实是分散在，
各个银行，
互联网银行，
里面的，
那我就是对比了，
各个利率，
然后找到了，
我最喜欢的，
那些产品，
这笔钱呢，
我就是不追求，
暴力,
我就希望，
那种,
每天打开账户，
看它稳稳的，
涨几块钱，
的这种，
确定性，
是我安稳，
GAP的底气，
所以我说嘛，
小柳的那种，
放到纳斯达克里面的钱，
不算存款哦，
不算这种，
稳稳的幸福，
风险很高，
没错,
那第二笔钱，
就是我花分出来，
一个高风险的，
娱乐,
或者说，
学习,
它的娱乐，
就是说，
在金融市场里面，
熬油的这种娱乐，
不是我们这种娱乐，
对,
对啊,
就是前面也分享，
我炒股，
上杠杆，
这种交过惨痛学费的经历，
所以我给股票，
投资市场，
放的这笔钱，
是我来支付，
学习理财的学费，
就是,
我不指望，
自己是在这个，
股票里面，
挣大钱，
然后,
翻断背，
而我把这个，
当做我的一个，
付费的兴趣爱好，
这是我给自己，
抱的一个，
兴趣爱好班，
就像有人花钱，
去学画画，
学滑雪，
我来学炒股，
那我在投资市场，
就是,
用我的真金白银，
去,
去玩,
然后去，
实际的，
那叫什么，
以身入局，
来找手感，
所以呢，
这笔钱，
赚了就是，
一个意外之喜，
赔了我就当，
交学费，
而这笔钱，
就完全不会影响，
我的正常生活，
我也不把它，
当做我的存款，
这把玩的是，
勾端局，
就你们听起来，
我现在的规划，
是不是还挺，
清晰的，
就是,
相当清晰了，
没错,
但,
最近这两年，
我遇到的，
一个问题就是，
刚才也讲，
这种,
存单呢，
一些固收，
理财的收益，
越来越低了，
嗯,
是的,
然后,
像大的存单，
你，最多就，
锁,
三年五年嘛，
你五年前，
锁的那个，
三个多点的，
那个产品，
你到现在，
就没有办法，
再维持这三个多点，
你,
因为你再续就，
一点多嘞，
一夜,
都跑不过通胀，
哎,
老师别骂了，
师傅别骂了，
我正还亏钱，
那关键是，
所以,
我最近，
跟我们，
小雨散的顾问老师，
聊的比较多的，
就是关于，
财富贤，
嗯,
关键字上线喽，
哇,
那,
老师也给了我，
很多新的，
理财思路，
就是我存的，
这笔,
差优嘛你，
就算能支撑，
我不上班几年，
那,
五年后呢，
十年后呢，
甚至,
等到我们，
六七十岁，
退休了，
真正干不动的时候呢，
嗯,
我还能，
保证这笔钱，
够花吗，
而且,
我们心里都清楚，
就是,
等我们这一代人，
老了,
我们的养老金，
可能,
不像我们，
爸妈那一代人，
那么丰厚嘞，
嗯,
就是,
只靠我们，
每个月的，
这一点微博的养老金，
你不可能，
维持你现在的，
生活质量的，
嗯,
而且,
你们不觉得，
在你,
年纪很大的时候，
有一笔很，
高昂的存款，
是一个很危险的事情吗？
哦,是,
我们经常听到，
很多人，
就是,
目标客户群，
就是老年人呢，
就是,
盯着老年人，
手里面的那点钱，
封老头，
封老太太的，
没错,
就感觉，
当你老了，
所有不怀好意的人，
都会稳了上来，
很害怕，
然后,
甚至是你的，
子女啊，
亲人啊，
就是趁你在，
你的判断力，
跟认知力，
都下滑的时候，
来骗你，
手里这点钱，
很多老人，
都是存了一辈子钱，
但可能老的时候，
买一些，
保健品，
或者买一些，
什么产品，
一下子就，
被诈骗了，
对啊,
老年人的鸡蛋嘛，
然后,
顺势换一些，
什么,
词聊床啊，
买个几万，
几万的，
一点都不带那个，
犹豫的，
保健品啊，
所以我就想说，
我想买财富显，
主要就是，
它安全，
稳定,
而且是强制的，
你们也知道，
保险,
它就要锁定，
很久的时间，
不是说，
五年,
我就能取出来，
而且它是，
白纸,
黑字,
收益,
写进合同的，
你可以直接，
在这个时候，
就锁定，
一个长期，
稳定的利率，
虽然,
也有缺点，
就是说，
前五年，
你如果硬要，
提前取出来的话，
就会有损失，
但是,
正因为如此，
用消费，
首养的一个念头，
你就可以，
把这一笔钱，
硬锁给，
未来的自己，
而且,
我一直很想，
买那个，
年金显嘛，
就是,
想给自己，
配置一份，
额外的养老金，
我觉得，
这个最大的意义，
就是,
不是说，
你翻了多少倍，
什么,
付利,
多少钱，
而是在于，
你,
现在,
趁自己，
还年轻，
给,
几十年后的自己，
留一道防线，
让你,
七老八十的时候，
每个月有一笔，
雷打不动的，
现金流，
打到你的卡里面，
哎,
我从来没想过，
这种问题，
我都是，
活一天算一天，
现在想一想，
确实我都没有想过，
我七老八十的时候，
要靠什么，
养活我自己，
对呀,
当然不行啊，
你想,
你现在，
就要靠你，
爸的养老金了，
等你老的时候，
你要靠谁啊，
老天救救我爸，
看你的孩子，
要靠你的养老金呢，
我有可能有完吗，
就没有的话，
怎么办呢，
确实,
我觉得，
就听完，
小李的这些大师课之后，
我就在想说，
你就像我自己的，
这个,
所谓的财务规划，
本身就已经很模糊了，
而且,
只解决了一个问题，
就是,
我日常怎么把这些钱，
暂且说，
把它存下来吧，
但是,
从来没有解决，
另外一个，
就是问题，
就是,
如果哪一天，
真的出了一件大事，
那谁来替我扛，
就是,
因为买房这件事情，
你想想看，
因为一个，
所谓的可能错误的，
买房决策，
我就,
我的净资产，
是不生反降的，
我的投资层面，
出现了这样的失误，
所以我就，
某种意义上反评了，
但是,
至少我现在，
还是有工作，
有收入的，
但如果哪一天，
我健康出了问题，
或哪一天，
我被财了，
我就再找不到工作了，
那我,
连下个月，
继续有钱入账，
继续上班这样，
基本的钱提都没有了，
对，我特别焦虑，
就是,
特别是我爸生病以后，
长期的一个恢复的过程，
我就感觉，
这就是因为我爸，
这么多年的，
他自己对自己，
养老的一个兜底嘛，
他才能，
保障他现在的一个生活，
就我意识到了，
这个的重要性，
那我自己，
现在没有一个存款，
去兜底，
没有一个养老的一个，
东西,
来保障我自己，
那我自己体检，
包括,
朋友们，
三十家了的，
同龄人们，
越来越多了，
我真的觉得，
就是健康这一块，
还是挺需要一个保障的，
而且要越早越好，
就是,
三十岁可能，
已经有一点，
比二十岁的那个，
要什么基础，
要差了是不是，
就是在买，
买这个显的这一块，
是吗?
重极显，
一定要越早买越好，
嗯,
你就是年龄越大，
或者是你做完，
医疗检查之后，
会更贵，
我都没有这个意识，
像我前段时间，
做体检，
已经查出了，
毛病,
那这个，
这个时候，
我再去买，
已经是，
比我查之前，
要,
要贵了，
嗯,
相信大家听到这里，
也感受到，
保险,
是抵御风险，
比较好的一个方式，
但今天，
我们不给大家推荐，
具体的，
某一款保险产品，
因为我们，
也还在，
学习的过程当中，
今天给大家分享的是，
大家都非常熟悉的，
金主妈妈，
小雨傘保险经济，
哦,
其实,
在小雨傘，
之前我就，
久闻大名了，
而且我一直想，
体验那个，
保险顾问，
咨询,
这次太幸运了，
刚好,
小雨傘，
找到我们合作，
那我们就可以走，
我们自己的链接喽，
哎,
这里可以插播吗，
就是,
之前,
小李在，
我们群里分享说，
什么时候，
我们能，
火到小雨傘，
来找我们合作，
这一天，
实现了，
哇,
人还是要有，
梦想,
对,
她最大的优势，
就是,
她不属于，
任何一家保险公司，
那这样的话，
她给我们，
讲解,
或者,
测评产品，
就会更加的，
客观全面，
而且比较高效，
因为,
他们可以，
一战士的，
帮你对接，
所有的这些，
保险公司，
以及,
帮你处理后续的，
理配,
对,
其实,
我妈呢，
早早的，
就给我们，
全家都配置了，
重极限，
但是,
然后,
保额多少的，
再加这套餐，
那套餐，
还有什么，
等待期，
免赔额，
那,
保险条款，
秘密麻麻的，
我真的，
长到看得我晕字，
而且,
就是,
每个保险公司的，
业务员，
肯定,
就只能推荐，
自己家的产品嘛，
嗯,
如果,
你想为了，
方案更好，
你就得自己，
一家一家的，
去对比，
去聊,
然后,
就连小李，
这么爱比较的人都崩溃，
那对于我来说，
就更加的复杂了，
但是呢，
如果有了巧遇散，
大家就可以，
想把自己，
买保险的这个目的，
告诉顾问，
那顾问老师呢，
会一步一步的，
去询问你的情况，
帮你梳理，
你现在的生活当中，
有什么样的风险点，
然后才会给你，
搭配,
这些你头宝的方案，
并且,
每一个这个保险产品，
也会告诉你，
怎么用，
然后,
为什么他这个保险，
适合你，
因为他会给你，
科普一些非常基础的，
保险常识，
包括我们刚才说，
最近在看的一些，
财富险呢，
顾问老师，
也会给你，
出一个，
利率的掩饰表，
然后帮你计算，
IRR什么的，
就非常的清晰，
哎，那这样说来，
其实都相当算，
一次学习了，
没错,
就不管大家，
买不买这个保险，
我都挺推荐，
大家去，
先做一次这个咨询，
一分钱，
买不了吃亏，
买不了上当，
真的,
然后把自己的，
财产啊，
健康状况啊，
梳理清楚，
能做一个，
保险的规划，
和学习，
真的是越早越好，
我觉得，
就是我们这一代，
把三十出头了，
这个阶段，
很值得去做的一件事情。
那我们会把小雨伞的，
这个一分钱的，
保险咨询服务，
领取方式，
放在收notes，
以及评论区的置顶，
有需要的听友，
可以点击链接，
领取哦。
另外关注，
小雨伞的公众号，
回复三十，
不仅可以一分钱，
预约这个咨询，
同时你还可以领取一份，
女性妨碍线，
记得发给自己的，
女性家人，
也看一看吧。
哇，好棒啊。
所以小李，
能不能跟我们再拆开来讲一讲，
你到底怎么存下，
这笔,
这个gap的钱，
然后你到底，
平常是怎么，
理财的呢？
在讲这一段之前，
我想先问问你们俩，
你们都是从什么时候，
开始接触理财的呀？
其实理财蛮小时候就开始，
因为我爸妈，
他们也会买一些理财产品，
这是我第一次听到，
所谓的，
一个理念，
而是一种产品，
就他们真的会去银行，
买那个东西，
叫做理财嘛，
然后他们的时候，
也是要去柜台，
然后要有一些，
相熟的那个，
理财经理，
或者说，
他们相熟的那个，
怎么讲，
财富经理吗？
会跟他说，
最近出了，
什么新的理财产品，
好高端哦你家，
年纪的，
然后多少多少钱，
这样,
然后就要去，
去银行抢这个额度，
对啦,
你爸妈能存下，
你买那个，
北京房产的钱，
肯定也是经过了一番，
运筹维吾，
哎呀,
老师不好意思，
我从来没接触过理财，
可以这样说吗？
我人生和理财，
没什么关系，
你们家也不理财吗？
你爸妈也不理财吗？
对呀,
就说嘛，
他们的，
存款也不是那么多，
或者说他们理财，
也不告诉我们，
理财偷偷理财，
知道的就是不理财，
我感觉他们就是，
散财不理财，
就是散给我们各路，
亲朋好友，
那原生，
就是有这样的家庭啦，
对呀,
原生家庭真的好重要，
我的理财，
就是受我爸，
遣疑默化的影响，
是的,
但是,
当然我爸妈那个年代，
他们两个也没，
受过什么财商教育，
但是,
就是我爸，
开始接触股票之后，
他就觉得，
理财这件事，
是越早学，
越好的嘛，
所以他就，
也特别希望，
我能早点，
去了解这些东西，
就是我爸妈，
他们就是很，
很朴实的，
以,
以护人家吧，
所以我们家都对，
理财没有概念，
就导致我对理财，
就没有，
任何的想法，
那我觉得可能是，
怪说了一种感觉，
就是,
理财就会把财散走，
你理不清楚，
就会,
比如说股市套劳，
刚刚说的那种，
就是,
从小在我看来，
股市是一个，
洪水猛兽，
你知道吗，
不可能说，
踏入这个地方，
是很危险的一个事情，
对,
像我爸那么爱看足球，
这么多年，
我们家就是纯看足球，
压根,
跟,
跟一毛钱，
钱的事都没有，
所以,
我们家就是那个，
拒绝黄，
拒绝赌，
拒绝黄赌赌，
所以,
我从小就是，
经常看到说，
哪一场足球，
哪一场球赛，
输了以后，
很多人就说，
上天才是，
我都不懂，
我说,
有那么爱吗，
你们这么爱阿根廷吗，
你们这么爱，
你们以为他是，
以为是纯粹，
因为阿根廷输了，
所以觉得，
难过我上天才，
对,
我说,
哇塞,
你这么爱，
英格兰输了，
这个人就崩溃了吗，
我说,
怎么会爱成这样，
原来他是，
背后有一些金钱的，
脚翼,
我不懂，
我觉得，
我还有一个点是，
我老觉得，
就是在理财这件事情上，
开源比，
节流更重要，
就是我会觉得说，
每个月，
靠理财，
多挣了两百三百的，
我不如，
长脸工资，
来得更实在，
我总有这样的想法，
就,
然后我还这么的，
不会理财，
我费尽心思，
无非就是，
一个月多收入，
可能,
能有一千块钱，
我撑死了，
那我有这个时间，
我去加个班，
我去那个怎么，
多长脸工资，
不是来得更实在吗，
我总有这样的想法，
你这就是，
倾势金钱，
你每一分钱，
都要很重要，
你走过路上，
那个,
看到一分钱，
你都要捡起来，
只有你重视了金钱，
金钱才会，
远远不断地，
涌向你，
好像那个传教的人，
有时候那个小时候，
偷拿家里的零花钱，
最后没花完，
我都会扔掉，
天哪,
扔哪里啊，
干嘛路上，
我能不能跟在你后面呢，
就是比如说我，
偷偷地，
拿了家里的五块钱，
出去,
然后我今天可能，
只花了两块三块，
回到家里，
我理应是一个，
没有钱的人吧，
但我身上有两个，
刚崩了，
哥他更能想吧，
不行,
我就会在某个地方，
把他偷偷地扔掉，
你就不能藏在，
你的文具盒里吗，
你也是散财童子，
书桌啊，
或者家门口的那个，
信报箱里面，
什么之类都可以，
啊,
哇,
我们都好补实哦，
甚至有点傻，
就说到，
就是你手里，
稍微有一点钱的时候，
其实就是大学嘛，
大学开始，
你才会有生活费，
我大学也是，
我们宿舍最会花钱的那个人，
好骄傲哦，
不好意思，
我们请是六个人嘛，
就有一次，
我记得非常印象深刻，
因为,
让我特别伤心，
就是,
当时太太尼克号重映，
要去电影，
我就特别想去电影院看，
你看看，
啥都跟你有关系，
太太尼克号重映，
你也要去看，
不是,
这么经典的世纪之作，
我那个，
他红的时候，
我很小嘛，
我说,
现在我大了，
我可以去电影院，
支持他的票房，
你又欠卡梅龙，
一张票了，
是吗?
你到底欠多少人钱呢？
And,
我可以在电影院，
欣赏这一部这个，
矿视齐作，
当时我也去看了啦，
对吧，对吧，
然后我就邀请我的社友去看，
他们就在那个，
宿舍领帐，
用电脑看什么，
快乐大北营啊，
那时候那些，
很多综艺节目嘛，
就一群人的客网子说，
有病啊，
去电影院看，
太太尼克号重映，
就是说那个，
电影票钱，
当时应该也有十几块吧，
反正还是有，
有点那个，
花安费的，
他们就说，
有病啊，
看这个，
就是把我损了一番，
我就气得摔门，
也不摔门，
就是我很伤心的，
离开了这个，
我就一个人去看了，
再加上他有这个悲剧嘛，
我真的是在电影院，
痛哭流涕，
就是,
一方面哭这个，
悲惨的这个，
故事,
一方面说，
我怎么没有人懂我，
就是你们这些，
现实的，
你们这些世俗的，
省钱的人，
就是,
我在,
大学的时候，
我印象深刻，
就这件事情，
我就说，
我跟这些人的消费官，
过不到一起去，
尿不到一个狐狸，
对,
那你们大学的时候，
生活费有多少钱啊？
有点没印象了，
你们记得嘛，
大概的数字，
可能是，
哦，我记得呀，
多少啊？
因为我每年，
就是我爸妈，
四个月嘛，
相当于一个学期，
我妈应该会在，
学期初的时候，
给我打，
大概,
八千,
到一万，不等，
她会看她的心情，
那你很多哎，
就是我现在回想起来，
每个月我大概，
应该是花到了，
嗯,
一千五到两千，
是肯定花了，
但是我从来没有一种，
觉得自己，
很有钱，
很富贵，
就是花了很多钱，
很怎么样的感觉，
也可能，
是不是北京的消费，
稍微高一点，
但是我就是，
一直觉得自己，
还是扣扣巴巴的，
然后到月底，
还是经常没钱，
或者说到，
这一个周期的，
快结束的时候，
也是没钱，
我还打工呢，
那时候，
我还去勤工减薄呢，
我印象中，
好像一个月时，
一千左右吧，
哇，一千？
大概是，
你们都是一千吗？
差不多啊，
因为重庆的消费，
还挺便宜的，
吃个小面，
而且我觉得，
女生,
应该没有男生吃的多，
所以,
男生的生活费，
应该会比女生高。
哎，是啦，
我大学的时候，
正是在那个，
bill the art的时候,。
什么?
正是在蒙掌的时候，
那时候吃的很多，
女生会出现一个花费，
就开始买一些化妆品啦，
还有一些，
小裙子，
小洞洞，
就是虽然，
不是那么的，
买,
但是也是一笔，
投资,
我想说的就是，
很多人，
就是我的同学，
他们的爸妈，
是按月给生活费的，
是的,
就,
但是我爸妈，
就是直接按年给，
一次性给我，
打一整年的生活费，
所以就是，
也有个，
几万块钱吧，
反正我手里是，
没经过上万的钱，
我记得我爸，
应该是会，
每个月定期打，
或者是有的时候，
我跟他说，
拜拜,
有点不够了，
可以在额外打一下吗？
对,
所以我从来没有，
额外跟爸妈，
要过钱，
那你就必须得有规划，
因为你是有一笔，
总的资产，
对,
就你想一个，
刚上大学的孩子，
然后你手里突然，
握了一大笔钱，
你就要，
去规划，
这一整年的支出嘛，
而且不知道是不是我，
因为我是金牛座，
我就是天生就喜欢钱，
就我不跟你俩似的，
我千金三金的，
我还往外扔钱，
散赛铜子，
我就是一直想，
从哪儿来，
搞点钱，
而且我想独立，
我有去打工什么的，
就虽然我的物欲不高，
但是我买东西的理念，
就是我一定要买好的，
我不要，
就是扣扣搜搜买一堆小破烂，
然后为了支持我，
这种买精品的，
这么一个消费官，
我就必须要，
去规划嘛，
确实,
但我就不是，
我就是经常买很多，
我上大学的时候，
买了很多破烂，
我也是啊，
我觉得直到我，
工作前一两年，
我还是买了很多破烂，
诶，淘宝那一期，
应该就分享了，
我们的购物订单，
乱七八糟，
而且淘宝，
已经变成，
精品购物平台之后，
有一个新的平台出现了，
它叫做，
PDB,
我真的觉得，
我买了很多，
尤其是，
刚刚开始自己住房的时候，
PDB评价加居好物，
或者是一些，
这儿来个小宽，
那儿在那个门后，
搞一个支架，
什么支屋架，
对,
而且买了很多，
什么一些，
你知道，
设计师款的，
凭屁,
就是看上去，
好像挺便宜的，
都什么，
二十几块，
三十几块，
但这些东西，
它们往往质量，
都非常的感人，
而且你仔细想想，
它们也不是那么的便宜，
它不是真的说，
你,
好像几块钱买个东西，
它还是要几十块，
而且它们最后还会，
很快的坏掉，
对呀,
对，你就觉得说，
它制造了你一个需求，
有时候你根本就是，
你也不需要这个东西，
你就打开PDD，
想说，我买点什么，
我今天就想买点什么，
我想要消费一把，
什么,
然后就买了很多没用的，
这种破烂，
花了很多没用的小钱，
我觉得，
反正我大学的时候，
我就去报一些，
股票相关的课程，
因为可以选修课嘛，
哇,
你才选修课？
对呀,
大学还有这样的课程，
因为我当时，
算是学商课，
所以就会有，
股票相关的，
然后当时要，
比如说模拟炒股，
或者说，
学化一些那个线呢，
是类的，
你要学会看那些线，
这样,
我大学选修了，
法语,
跟我的人生有半毛钱关系嘛，
Bungju,
Match,
我大学选修了，
陶艺,
我们在那儿考陶土，
很好啊，
我,
这我都很想学也，
然后同时我大学，
也看了很多的那个，
理财书，
比如说什么，
穷爸爸，富爸爸，
然后小狗浅浅这些，
哦,
你们都有看过吗？
我都有在机场，
跟他们打过照面啦，
他们放在机场的那个，
书店里面，
我会在门口，
路过他们，
真的吗，
这是很基础的理财书吧，
我,
默认大家都有看过，
no no no,。
然后,
我当时就开始，
每天非常精细的记账，
就是,
花了多少钱，
精确到小数点，
后一位，
哦,
天呐,
我记账经常开启，
从未坚持，
我觉得我长这么大，
我自己需要，
就是后来有一些，
主动自动记账软件，
出现之后，
它可以自动读取你的那个，
消费的记录嘛，
那种可能还记过，
但是以前真的要靠自己，
一笔笔记的记账，
没有超过过三天，
你是ADHD的一种，
而且还会做假账，
就是,
这个钱，
这个钱不是我的，
是日常消费，
它是突发的，
我要把它摊到
每个月头上去，之类的，
啊，有一些欺骗自己的小动作，
对,
反正我当时就是，
看那些书嘛，
我觉得那些书，
对我影响最大的一个理念，
就是说，
它说人不能，
一直靠工资来赚钱，
哦,
你要有属于自己的资产，
让资产，
替你赚，
税后收入，
就是,
要有被动收入，
税后,
就在你睡觉的时候，
还有人帮你在挣钱，
然后当时它，
认为的资产，
就是房产跟股票嘛，
因为,
就是很早，
那个时段写的书，
所以,
大家一直觉得，
房产是一个很固定的，
那个很稳固的一个资产，
所以我，
当时就是很，
心里就只有一个目标，
我想说，
我要攒钱买房子，
然后让这个房子，
租出去，
挣这个房租，
毕拜好物，
来帮我挣钱，
哎,
我记得很早的时候，
确实,
最早有买房想法的，
好像就是小礼，
就我们，
读书的时候，
小礼也会说，
以后要，
怎么怎么买房，
要干嘛干嘛，
对呀,
就当时还是觉得嘛，
觉得你要有这个，
固定资产嘛，
然后,
也是大学那个时候，
我第一次，
接触到了fire这个理念，
ifiree,
What's this?。
提前退休，
你没听过吗？
我只知道，
哎哎哎哎哎哎，
to anyone,。
豆瓣上有一个很有名的小组，
就叫fire小组，
他的核心理念，
就是说，
当你的资产，
当你理财产生的收益，
可以cover掉你的日常开销的时候，
你现在就是财富自由啰，
你就不上班了，
你就可以不上班，
就可以提前退休了，
比如说，
你的生活费需要5000块钱，
那当你的存款投资，
或者那个时候说是房产，
然后产生的比如说租金，
你每个月能够产生，
稳定的5000块钱的现金流的时候，
你就可以不用工作了，
但我听到，
但我当时看到这个的心情的就是，
哎，那我继续工作不是更好吗？
我还可以赚两份工资的钱，
爱上班的这个种子，
在那个时候就埋在心里，
也是啦，
反正我当时就觉得这个理念，
对我影响很大，
因为我就发现，
我其实真正想要的不是说，
我赚一大笔钱，
我要成为有钱人，
因为我也没有特别强烈的那个，
消费的欲望嘛，
但是我更想要的就是，
有一天我可以不用，
因为钱去工作，
去逼自己工作，
确实,
就不用去第三下一次的，
低声下气的去求人了，
如果我不喜欢当下的工作，
我就是有权利，
让自己停下来调整，
就有更多的选择嘛，
反正回到我自己身上，
我觉得理财的第一步，
不是投资，
而是,
要先了解自己，
因为很多人存不下钱，
就是因为，
你们根本不知道钱花去哪儿了，
你不知道自己需要多少钱，
不知道自己一个月，
最低的生活成本是多少，
也不知道，
如果有一天你没收入了，
你需要准备多少钱，
才能让自己安心，
然后刚才也说，
大学开始我就一直记账嘛，
后来我去韩国留学的时候，
也在很精确的记账，
你们都不知道我的记账方式，
因为那个时候，
我们还流行那个实体存折嘛，
韩国,
通账,
然后我每个月底，
最上头的一件事情，
我要去那个ATMG，
来打印通账，
因为它会把每一笔留水，
都,
就是印在你的那个存折上面，
那岂不是你的通账，
三点两都要坏心的，
对啊,
当时我就在韩国，
只用这一张卡消费，
我也不用什么现金，
也不用其他的，
什么方式，
这一笔，
就是这一个卡，
就是我完全的支出卡，
然后呢，
我就会把这上面的留水，
跟我自己记得账，
逐一对账，
我好喜欢对账哦，
那你买那什么，
三千五千的那小零食也，
三千五千可不是小之处啊，
小零食，
不是，就是，之类的吧，
我就举个例子，
就这样的钱，
当然了，
你每一笔都要记，
不然你才，
你怎么能精确的，
统计自己，
在吃的方面的花费，
你吃的，
你哪会，
一下子就吃个，
十万块钱的，
东西,
你不都是这三千五千，
积累起来的吗，
每天不是就是，
回家路上随手拐进便利店，
然后进行一番消费，
回去了，
就这些小冬冬，
你看,
很难算呢，
我在我概念里，
就是很难算呢，
我觉得比起这个，
这个都还好，
因为这个比起你是刷卡，
你要是拐进街头小巷，
买了那个三个鸡鱼饼，
我买了两串鸡肉串的，
都付现金的，
更难,
我回头就忘了，
那就要立马寄到你的那个，
鸡帐本上，
你的备忘录里面啊，
你一天消费有十笔吗，
of course,。
每天都在，
这里花一点，
那里花一天呢，
没有吧，
你想一想，
你每天不会有花十几笔的，
这个花费，
就是我的意思是，
它没有那么费劲，
你每次花完，
就只需要打几个数字而已，
对,
我们老把这个事情，
觉得很费劲，
跟很繁琐，
但其实没有那么大，
我们有很多碎片时间，
都花在没有用的地方上面，
对啊,
所以就是，
你们先不要想，
更远的什么，
理财,
我要不要买股票，
要不要买基金，
你首先要从第一步，
就是最基础的，
这个自己，
了解自己的消费结构，
开始。
我当时也找我朋友，
给我进行一些，
那个理财推荐，
他也是就是，
专门做投资相关的，
在投资方面，
很有力的一位朋友，
听到就好像麦克，
他也是跟我说，
他跟我讲到，
就是一模一样的话，
他说,
你要先算清楚，
你每个月的固定支出，
然后你要算，
你大概，
月数乘你每个月的，
这个最低生存成本，
然后你就会知道，
你需要多少钱是，
绝对不能够，
发生变故的，
然后你再去算，
你有多少投资的需求，
你,
应该可以获得多少，
理财的方面的收益，
总之,
听完,
也很像一个天书，
但是我至少知道，
就是,
要知道自己一个月，
花多少钱，
是一个正常水平，
不能乱花，
对呀,
那要是想乱花，
怎么办呢？
那你就要，
提前把那个乱花的钱，
出来,
就是我很想问，
就是,
这个预算这件事情，
怎么规划呀？
就像我很喜欢追星，
我就,
我无法预判，
我未来将会买什么样的，
门票和，
花多少钱去，
追这个东西，
那,
形成随时有变化呀？
你,
你不能让这个变化干扰你，
你要有一个，
比如说，
今年我的追星之处，
就是这么多，
比如说，
就是两万块，
你超过，
你就不能去了，
对呀,
你不能说，
又开了一场，
又发现了新的变化，
那还得去，
那没着钱呢，怎么办？
万一，爱上新的偶霸呢，
爱上一个韩国人，
或者泰国人，
怎么办呢？
或者说，
你就要提前，
往你这个储蓄罐里面存钱，
你开一个，
专门的追星小金库，
你定期，
我有现金流的时候，
我挣钱的时候，
我定期，
每个月就往这里面存，
每个月存个五百块钱，
然后,
这里面的钱，
就是你，
到时候，
才能花的，
但是你不能把，
把新的钱，
或者买衣服的钱，
再挪到这个金库里面，
你不能给自己做假账，
就是,
你要诚实地，
面对你自己，
你这么多钱，
你就只有这么多钱，
你不能花超，
你要是爱上别人，
那你就是，
你得把以前那个断掉，
你要跟前男友断掉，
你才能给新的男友花钱，
你不能说，
我又,
既想养他，
又想养他，
你要养多少人呢？
这一点，
这一点我相信，
他做得很好，
他一般都是前男友断掉，
而去新的男友断掉，
只不过，
他要上头花的比较多，
对,
就是,
上头的话，
会花的更多，
所以,
你要有归花，
老师,
我误了，
得提前把这个东西，
赞出来，
没错,
就你得有钱，
才能去，
你不能没钱，
还硬去，
虽然说，
人生就是靠硬去，
我的,
我的优点，
就是,
我还不会花，
预支的钱，
就是,
我不会用信用卡，
或者花贝的钱，
去消费这一笔收入，
因为我知道，
卡跟花贝是，
很好的，
理财方式，
那都太高阶了，
他的意思是说，
他至少不会把，
那个没有的钱，
花掉了，
然后到最后，
对，我至少不会花，
我没有的钱，
去消费我自己，
本来不应该消费的东西，
好啦,
给你一个荣誉大拇指，
哎呀,
谢谢你，
所以,
那我就要，
刘浩存举手了，
老师,
我要怎么，
赞钱的，
除了刚刚说的，
了解自己的消费之外，
除了刚刚说的那个，
先提钱预支之外，
我还能做一些什么呢？
这不就是，
最好的一个方法吗？
就是,
你要先了解，
我每个月大概，
吃多少钱，
比如说，
三千块，
那我就知道，
我每个月，
要留三千块，
放到我吃饭的，
这个,
储蓄罐里面，
那比如说，
我挣了五千块，
我就知道，
这三千块，
我一定要稳固地放在这，
剩下两千块，
才是我，
能花的钱，
好的,
理论都学习了，
现在是实践，
你不能说，
哎，我一看我存款，
我还有个几万块呢，
我随便花，
那你不想想你，
将来咋办呢？
是的,
就是我的人生，
好的,
这句课，
学习了很多，
听上去很像，
只上了五分钟，
就让老师，
离开的那种，
我很怀疑，
这个同学，
心成不成，
会不会，
实操这件事情，
接下来，
看我的表现吧，
然后就去美国了，
去日本了，
花的越来越多，
就说明，
提前要，
要攒的钱，
要变多了，
对啦,
是啦,
就是这样没错啦，
就好像我现在不是，
也面临几笔大的支出嘛，
一个是我国庆要去，
欧洲玩，
然后另外一个就是，
我可能明年年初要，
想买车，
然后还有一点，
就是我手头，
我现在还欠着一笔，
装修的装修袋，
就是我当时也是，
出于那个，
他可以无期分析的这个心情，
就耗了这个羊毛，
选了分期来，
还这个装修袋款，
但他其实也需要在，
二零二二八年，
就要把那一笔钱，
还掉了，
所以我要提前去了解说，
我那个时候，
到底还要还多少钱？
就因为我每个月，
其实也在还嘛，
所以那个时候，
会还一个剩下的，
剩的本金，
要把这个钱算出来，
把这笔钱先留好，
但是我就，
没有办法进行，
更高难度的规划了，
比如说，
我其实现在，
不需要花这笔钱，
先规划出来，
我可不可以在这段时间，
给它进行一些理财，
或者让它先前生前一下，
我不行，
我就想说，
哦，那这个钱，
我就把它放在活期里面好了，
我把哪一天被我花掉，
或者买一个，
死机的那种，
就让它一直，
稳固地停留在那里，
这就是我的那个理财之道。
你们这边有一个，
很有意思的理论，
叫做,
三十万反评定律，
什么动作。
是什么？
听上去好令人害怕哦。
就是说，
很多人呢，
就是说我们，
比如说中国的，
这十四亿人，
里面说现在是十四亿人吗？
只有百分之多少，
就很少的一个，
份额的人，
他才会攒购，
他才会有，
三十万以上的存款。
很多人呢，
他攒购三十万之后，
他的智商会突然下线，
然后我们就会觉得，
我有钱了，
然后就开始，
买房买车，
各种乱折腾，
然后迅速反评。
哦,
因为三十万这个数字呢，
他很微妙，
你离那个什么，
第一个一百万，
第一个一千万那种，
大额资产，
离财富自由，
还远得很，
但是呢，
你又刚刚好觉得，
哎,
我有点钱，
就是一个，
让人膨胀的，
一个临界点上，
所以,
当你的存款，
到达三十万的时候，
这是一个很危险的，
数字。
我在点谁，
我就不说了。
老师,
怎么办？
我感觉自己，
面临好多危机，
这个谁要害我？
又危机似乎，
又货又那么多。
对啊,
还不是你们之前教育我要，
那个未体验买单吗？
怎么回事？
真是去欧洲了，
怎么又开始劝足我了呢？
见不得我好吗你们？
如果你，
那个行动力没那么强，
只是一个停留在想法的话，
还能收住，
但是你现在已经把那个，
签证啥都烙听了。
自己票都买了啦。
不是让你这个月，
少点支出啦，
就少买那个一千块的耳机，
一万块的那个手机啦。
是啊,
对,
就是我，
我好歹还是会知道说，
我接下来要花这个钱了，
那我就会开始想说，
哦,那,
这最近就收敛一点。
我昨天，
出去那个去商场，
可是做公交去的。
很好啊。
好棒棒哦。
很好,
可能很喜欢自己这样的那个，
我现在省钱很大一笔，
就是说我不开车了，
因为停车费和油费还挺贵的，
我就会选择，
要不就是，
近一点就走路，
或者骑车，
远一点就公交。
反正在时间多嘛。
对身体也很好啊。
然后另外就是，
我刚刚讲的，
之前那个买破烂的这个行为，
我现在也会尽量的收敛它，
改而去买一些比较贵的大件。
就是,
长期主义这个词大家都有听过啦，
对吧。
就像我自己来说，
我可能买的，
不是说什么衣服鞋子包，
我去买很贵的东西，
但是我会在别的方面，
我会适当的去，
在我自己的消费能力里面，
去买一些，
相对来说高价一点，
但是有品质，
而且能长久用的东西。
就像刚刚讲的，
这些日常的家居，
或者是别的这种，
日常生活当中，
用的这些东西，
你买那种破烂，
其实你心里，
它不仅坏的很快，
而且你心里，
还总是想要买那个原版。
就是那个平屁，
它能平下此时的这个，
能力上的平屁，
那它在你的情绪上，
是剃不了的。
老师，我那个通俗的理解，
就比如说你今天，
就想吃一碗螺丝粉，
今天晚上，
然后想说算了算了，
就这个点了，
我先啃一个黄瓜吧，
又觉得不行，
我还是开一包饼干吧，
还是没包，
饼干之后又啃了一个包面包，
最后呢，
还是打开了一袋螺丝粉，
就比你，
直接吃螺丝粉，
还是多吃的饼干。
热量涉入还高。
我在这方面，
最早的尝试，
就是手机壳，
我以前总买一些，
那个便宜很烂的手机壳，
8块10块,
那个PDD手机壳，
但是你，
但是因为我其实，
我对手机壳，
我没有什么花样上的那个喜好，
我其实就喜欢透明，
手机壳，
然后它要能够，
足够的保护好我的手机，
就可以了，
但是呢，
你知道透明手机壳，
如果你买便宜的，
它最大的问题，
就是很容易发黄，
是的,
它用不了多久，
就开始发黄，
会打油，
用久了之后，
就开始很滑，
然后你就很想把它扔掉，
这个东西有时候，
都走不了两个月，
就一个月多一点，
它就,
你就觉得这个东西，
好恶心，
我这么高价的一个手机，
包在一个这么，
破破烂烂的手机壳里面，
就是自己档次都低了，
然后后来呢，
就有一个相对高质量的，
这个手机壳品牌出现了，
完全不会挑它的牌子，
反正它就是，
平均价大概在200多左右，
不是那个C打头，
那个漂亮壳，
就是支架壳，
因为我对支架的这个东西，
需求很大，
我老是吃饭的时候，
把手机架弄来看视频，
没有了，
然后这个手机壳，
听我讲完，
这个手机壳200块钱，
我十大十的用了两年多，
它到最后都是非常好的，
完全没有发黄，
直到我最后换手机，
它那个手机壳，
才离我远去，
我第一次用一个透明壳，
两年都没有发黄，
而且你知道，
有时候买那种支架，
那个支架的那个脚链，
就很容易松，
你用一段时间，
它就撑不住了，
它就会滑倒，
但那个手机壳，
它的那个手机壳，
也是完全没有松开，
所以我后来，
我逢人就推荐那个手机壳，
但大家都会说，
买200多的手机壳，
有病吗？
对呀!
但我就想说，
买这一个，
你就可以几年都不换，
然后另外就是，
延续到这个大建的消费上，
这次不是装修房子吗？
以前我基本上都会去买一些，
什么移家，
或者甚至买一些，
更便宜的一些，
网上的一些家具的牌子，
但这次我就也买了一些，
在我自己的，
消费能力范围内，
相对比较高价的产品，
我觉得它的好处就是，
当它,
出现在你家的时候，
你看到它那个设计跟质感，
都是你所想象的，
你想要的那个样子，
你就会满意了，
你就死心了，
你从此不会下去看，
别的那个，
家具推荐评测的那种帖子了，
我觉得这个长期主义，
对于我来说，
就是,
适合我这种，
我知道自己想要的是什么，
就是最好的东西是什么样子，
或者相对比较好的东西，
是什么样子，
而且我达到了之后，
我就心满意足了，
我不会一天到晚变心了，
所以这个东西最好就是，
在你的生命里面有一个，
就够了那种大剑，
但如果你是，
你说,
啊,
我要买一个很名贵的包，
因为它我要追求长期主义，
所以我要买一个3万5的包，
但是这个包，
你包不能只有一个吧，
然后你就会，
结果你打开你的衣柜，
全是长期主义，
一柜子长期主义，
那就不行啊，
然后,
这种我就不欣赏了，
所以就是，
在一些，
你只要买一个就好的东西上面，
而且要花很，
要用很久的这种东西上面，
我觉得，
相对的花一点，
大价钱，
对于我来说，
是我现在的一个，
比较好的消费观念的方式。
那你提到这个，
长期主义，
我感觉我的投资理念，
其实也是这样的，
就是,
刚才,
好，我花钱，你赚钱，
你就要飞在这里打击，
不是啦，
就是,
刚才也说，
我们那个，
存了一笔钱，
那你另外的这些钱，
你要放到投资市场里面去了吗？
那我一开始的那个，
就我投资经历也，
折腾过不少方面，
比如说一开始，
大家我们，
最先,
接近的，
无非就是基金，
黄金,
这种债机，
这种比较稳的产品嘛。
嗯。
然后后面，
买基金，
买到我觉得，
哎，如果，
我看好一个公司，
我为什么不直接买呢？
因为,
就相当于，
这个基金的，
主理人，
他去买这个股票嘛。
嗯。
然后你有的时候，
调仓什么的，
就是他的调仓，
你也不是很，
快速的就能知道，
而且,
就是,
可能,
我只认可他的，
几个股票，
那剩下的股票，
我其实是不认可的。
但他却要打包卖给你？
没错,
我觉得他的灵活性，
就不如股市，
所以不如，
我就直接开始，
啊,
以身入局，
自己,
进到股市里面，
去,
做T,
你就可以当天买卖，
就可以，
做T,
被爱做T，
啊，你啊，
第一买高卖了，
反正就是，
你可以，
自己很灵活的，
去操作这笔钱嘛。
然后,
包括我，
不是一直，
是一个很喜欢，
尝试新东西的人，
我也是学了一个，
什么,
websan啊,。
就这种，
新的投资领域，
但是,
刚才我不是说了吗，
就是我平时，
是一个很谨慎的人，
结果到了，
投资市场，
我完全变了，
你们,
听过那个段子吧，
就是说，
我看了很多兵法，
那个谁，
忽兰说的，
我看过很多兵法，
学习了很多知识，
但那一刻，
我还是上头了，
听过很多道理，
但依然过不好这一生，
没错,
然后我就觉得，
不要有，
这种,
极功尽力的想法，
去投资，
你就是以一个，
长期主义的想法，
你这笔钱，
我就不要了，
我不上头，
就是每天的涨跌，
我都心如之水，
你反而，
带着这种想法，
才能熬过，
这个漫长的时间，
周期,
我觉得这一点，
我能做到，
你不能拿着你，
因为上次，
我不是那个，
重金进入，
韩国股票市场了吗？
我大概已经，
一周没打开过，
股票软件，
那很好啊，
我忘记这笔钱了，
对,
你就是要忘记，
你就是把这笔钱，
放进去之后，
你就,
没有掉了，
你就当这笔钱，
不存在，
然后你过一段时间，
再去看，
反而,
就有一些惊喜，
就类似于，
在兜里，
放一张纸币，
在N年后，
翻出来了，
没错,
就是你不能拿，
你输不起的钱，
去投资，
对,
我还是那句话，
那这笔钱，
你可以直接，
当它不存在，
我可以把它直接，
扔掉,
没有压力的时候，
你反而能，
做出更理性的判断，
嗯,
有些人，
为什么，
就是好多人，
经常跳楼，
啥的,
经常跳楼的，
朋友们都知道，
经常上天台的，
你就是用了，
你输不起的钱，
去投资，
你才会，
就是自己的那个，
身心灵上，
有那么大的，
起伏,
跟变化，
嗯,
最近不是说，
韩国黄金时代结束了吗，
我在那个，
茶上刷到很多人，
就说,
他们公司的那一个，
什么科长，
前两天，
还信匆匆的，
请大家吃饭，
最近就已经，
面如死灰，
像个死人一样，
一问就是，
把各种什么，
老婆本官在本，
什么全部放进去炒了，
还借贷杠杆，
这种就肯定不行了，
对呀,
就是你，
不上这么多杠杆，
你可能，
但你也不会亏，
很大一笔钱，
对,
我理解就是，
比如说你，
如果没有上杠杆的话，
你哪怕，
十万块钱的股票，
它再亏，再亏，
再亏,
变成两万三万了，
哪怕就这样亏了，
你还是有一点点钱，
在里面的嘛，
但你上了杠杆，
一旦平仓了，
爆仓了，
你就是变成零了，
那怎么，
肯定是不一样的，
你根本就没有翻身的资本了，
你就破产了，
对呀,
而且我前面，
就是,
我们以前对资产的理解，
可能就是什么房产呢，
然后包括股票啊，
这种固定的资产，
然后让它前生前嘛，
但是我现在觉得，
市场变了，
我们对资产的理解，
可能也变了，
你现在拥有一套房产，
它可能，
就不是一个那么好的投资标的了，
你可能，
不是,
不是北京了，
就是北京这种地方，
当然还是很中心的位置，
你还是，
寂希望于市场，
就你不会亏成零嘛，
但是,
一些小城市的，
比如说，
郊区的一些房产，
你可能到后面，
就是卖不出去了，
那它,
肯定不会给你带来，
现金流了，
反而是一个，
你很难处理的一个资产了，
负担,
所以我现在觉得，
我们要积累的反而是，
自己一个多元化的技能，
就是,
能给你带来，
本职之外的一些收入，
比如说你，
我就说嘛，
还是要多挣钱啊，
没错,
就是你会一些什么，
剪辑的技能啊，
或者你会，
做咖啡啦，
就是,
当你在你的那个，
本职,
本职工作，
受到冲击的时候，
你也可以用，
自己额外的技能，
去其他的赛道，
来给自己挣钱，
保障现金流了，
我还有个感悟就是，
钱这个东西，
它除了它具体，
就是,
怎么说，
一个狭窄定义的钱，
它有种就是，
更广泛的定义，
比如说，
我们自己的身体健康，
是不是也算是一种，
价值吧，
它不能说是钱，
对,
因为你身体不健康，
你就要花钱，
比如说，
现在我最近，
我也开始健身了嘛，
我会觉得说，
那我是不是让我的身体，
更稳健以后，
到我老的时候，
生病的概率，
就会增，
减小,
那我可能，
反而也是，
对我的未来的一个投资，
我的身体身上，
或者是投资到，
我自己的一个心理健康，
就是,
比如说我，
我去运动以后，
我感觉好像那个，
焦虑的情绪，
明显少了一些，
就可能，
睡眠也好了，
就这些方面，
安全感增加了，
那可能也是一种，
投资,
这方面的一种投资，
没错,
对,
健康就是最大的财富，
我就是最近看到，
一句话说，
人生最重要的，
五大要素，
平静,
睡眠,
肌肉量，
好的代谢，
然后最后一个就是，
现金流，
就除了这五点，
其他都是，
白噪音，
我就觉得，
基于这个哲学，
那我现在消费的，
逻辑就特别清晰，
因为前四点，
其实就是，
健康嘛，
就像特德刚才说的，
你要保证好的，
睡眠,
那我可能就，
很舍得，
把钱去投资在，
比如说，
好的,
好的枕头，
这期要，
多少产品，
床品,
床品要投资，
你知道吗，
都来找我们，
这是一些，
什么枕头啊，
床品呢，
能让我来睡个好觉，
能让我精神饱满，
然后,
包括什么，
肌肉量和好的代谢，
就要求我们，
要健康饮食，
跟运动健身嘛，
所以在这两个方面，
我也会很舍得，
花钱,
那,
内心的平静，
其实就是精神健康，
那,
我们刚才说的一些，
什么,
体验呢，
或者,
可以治愈我们的事情，
对,
其实这也是一个，
嗯,
很好的投资，
我个人，
觉得是一个，
很好的投资了，
我是觉得，
我会愿意投入，
我的金钱，
到那种，
让我可以，
进入心流的那种体验，
不管是，
画画呀，
或者,
刚才你说，
陶艺呀，
然后什么，
插花呀，
反正这种，
手工艺，
评斗啊，
没错,
评斗,
我觉得这些都，
很治愈我们的心灵，
反而,
能让我们更加健康，
然后,
放松下来的那个，
兴趣爱好，
就是,
啊,
追行,
就不说了，
我觉得，
这些东西听起来，
最后得到的三个字，
就是,
安全感，
不管是你是健康，
还是你心里，
有很平稳，
还是你有，
就是健康的这个，
消费规划，
总之就是你，
为了,
任何一种事情，
感觉到很担心，
感觉到，
非常担心受怕，
那你这样的话，
你整个人就是，
快乐跟，
平稳的，
我们所有的钱，
跟所有的理念，
其实都应该给自己，
买一份安心感，
对啦,
你看,
你说那个，
最后那个现金流，
其实就是，
在我们，
有工作能力的时候，
我们去找，
工作,
或者是，
不断,
争取,
更高的薪资，
来保障我们，
现在的现金流，
那日后的现金流，
我们要给自己，
配置那个，
养老金嘛，
就是让我们，
之后,
也有稳定的，
现金流，
你们现在，
最舍得，
为什么花钱嘛，
就是你，
最不心疼的，
一笔钱，
是什么？
小李刚刚讲过了，
那我来讲的话，
就是我，
开始渐渐地，
学习,
为,
体验买单，
就是为一些，
在,
我现在这个岁数，
能够做的一些，
开心的事情，
适度的花一点钱，
欧洲旅游啦，
对,
会做的事情，
因为,
在北漂时期，
我们经常一起，
出去吃饭，什么的，
感觉小柳，
就特别务实，
因为那会，
压力比较大，
压力可能比较重，
对，就经常说，
哎呀,
不要买那个了，
哎呀，不要买那个了，
就是，过得比较紧，
我以前，
经常会劝阻，
那个特特的，
很多那个，
精神文化的消费，
现在劝不住了，
哈哈,
山高皇帝远啦，
现在自己也想，
要去精神世界，
快乐一下啦，
啊，该快乐，
对，然后也希望，
最后结尾，
要落点头在这儿嘛，
最后落到，
那个还是要快乐，
什么,
该花就花，
哈哈,
他等了，
啊，你就，
你就花完了，
你花完这笔钱了，
嗯,
我花完了，
哈哈,
就是我现在，
依旧还是，
没有觉得那笔钱，
不值得花，
就哪怕现在，
翻回头来说，
哇，这个门票好贵，
曾经还为了TXT，
花那个四千，
买一张票，
什么的，
就我,
翻回头来，
肯定觉得他是贵的，
但是,
当时我觉得，
那就是我想要去，
做的一件事情，
但他,
当时的物价，
他就是那样，
所以也没有什么，
值得去后悔的，
这是我的一个，
消费理念吧，
嗯,
那,
我觉得反过来，
我现在最不舍得花的，
就是一切那种，
虚荣的面子消费，
跟,
跟风的那种消费，
嗯,
就是,
为了证明自己，
过得不错，
我买一个，
什么,
张显自己身份的，
包,
反正就是，
买那些，
没那么需要的东西，
或者说，
现在拉布布很流行，
那我也要买拉布布，
我就是，
很不欣赏这种消费，
哎呦,
这儿很流行，
那什么暴力熊，
还是什么的，
就是那个，
五颜六色，
花花绿绿的那个熊，
好多人跟踪买，
那个还蛮贵的，
我觉得，
这些跟风的东西，
都很贵，
嗯,
你翻回头来看，
因为他们就在风口上，
但我觉得你要真心喜欢的话，
你买也还行，
但是,
有很多人就是，
我不知道我喜不喜欢，
但是大家都这样做，
我才去消费了，
我就,
不是很建议哦，
我本人最心疼的，
当然就是当年那套房的首富啦，
还有什么口说的吗，
哎,
但是换来，
你现在安稳的，
居住环境啊，
你生长贪，
你知啦，
就是如果你有考虑买房的话，
就是你要好好想清楚，
此时此刻是不是，
最需要这套房的时候，
以及,
未来你的，
现金流也好，
跟你自己的生活的变化，
会不会导致你这套房，
可能以后无法满足你的需求，
要多问问自己，
不要做很急的打算啦，
虽然我花了那么多消费啊，
我都不觉得是后悔的，
但一定要后悔的话，
我觉得我买了很多，
刚刚也，
说过的那种，
PDD小费物，
就也是类似平提的那样个概念，
就是我也说，
哎，你不觉得吗？
就是你本来想买的那个东西，
你打开平台，
你就忘了，
他的推荐也会给你推荐很多，
你觉得很有用的东西，
然后,
一下单可能买了七个八个，
但忘了自己最开始要买的那个是什么，
所以就买的那些东西好像，
比如说我买过那个，
我就举一个例子啊，
就是,
不是说拿手看书，
手一直撑着那个，
那个书的中间部位很费力嘛，
就会有一个那个，
小,
怎么形容，
是那种零型的一个，
压书时，
手指上可以，
压书神器，
对，就是你，
你手指头套在那上面，
你就可以很方便的压住那个书页，
你就不用很费力的，
来回按嘛，
怕它翻页，
哎,
从来没有打开过，
首先就不看书，
为什么要买那个按书神器啊，
我有一天翻，
翻件了，
我连那个包装袋都没有拆开，
我买它干嘛，
你家的应该有不少，
这种没拆开包装袋的怪递吧，
是,
所以我就很心疼这些，
你说它都不是，
都不是大钱，
但是加起来应该也不少了，
我比较心疼这种东西，
所以还是，
第一需求是你真的要用它，
你马上就要，
用上它的东西再去买，
这样还是比较好的，
没错,
这就是不记账啊，
你如果记账的话，
你就会发现，
哇，我一年花了很多钱，
在这种没有用的东西上，
我以后再买的时候，
我脑子里面就会过一下，
好的老师，
听上去也是没有在那个，
class over,。
很敷衍的一个好的，
一个学生，
总之啦，
听完这一集，
如果你也想跟我们一起聊一聊，
你觉得人生第一次发现，
自己,
应该开始存钱的时候，
是什么时候的话，
在我们节目下面，
跟我们评论，
也可以加入我们的听友群，
然后对这一集呢，
如果你感兴趣，
也记得要点赞，
订阅,
分享,
跟收藏，
这次终于讲对了，
不想做，
老讲,
我听得好认真啊，
每次都想记得要订阅，
跟关注，
都一样的话，
然后也再次感谢小雨散，
保险经济，
对我们这一集的赞助，
跟支持，
谢谢,
然后对他的这个，
资讯服务感兴趣的话，
记得要去看一下，
我们的shownotes,。
跟评论区，
那我们这集就到这结束咯，
下集再见，
拜拜,
下期见，